[Music]
n
w
[Music]
oh
he
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two Pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now walked right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God
why an arm get
in it's the fight to challenge Magnus
Carlson in the grand finals three
players in the arena only one will
survive welcome everyone to the
trustable Masters I'm back with the boys
grandmas Robert H and grandmas David
Howell before we get to the chest David
Robert did you guys coordinate your
outfits
who wore it better we need to know CH we
need to
know who wore it better that's the
question that's the first question for
chat and who plays better today will be
the big question in the action that is
coming up Robert before we discuss the
bracket right off the bat who do you
think makes it to the Grand Final oh
well I'm going to answer that with
Magnus Carlson because I know that he's
already there but Magnus he is not
playing today or tomorrow so if you made
me choose
it's too difficult so I'm going to pass
and throw back to you Tony come on who
do you think is going to make
it it's a tough one I did put you on a
spot well you chose a safe bet there but
let's point this out that for danis
lavic he plays only one match today we
will be starting with ala against Yan
nepom Nishi let's bring up our bracket
it's right here the two players who have
been in the losers bracket since the
star they got knocked down on day one on
Friday y n alira fuja making it through
to the losers semi-final on the way Yan
knocks out Maxim V lra knocks out
Vladimir FV Ali RZA fuja on his part
takes down Wesley St and Jose Martinez
they fight against each other the winner
of this match will play against Dennis
lazovic for that spot to challenge
Magnus Carlson in the Grand Final Robert
you asked me who do I think is that
second player who will fill in that
blank I've been really impressed by
everyone that we see the three players
in front of us but I'm going to go with
Ali Resa peruja what about you David oh
I'm going to Buck the trend I'm going to
uh support the Old Guard here my
generation Yan naom Nishi it feels like
he's ridden his luck against Maxim Vash
against fed he was on the brink of
elimination twice but he's survived he's
still there and experience counts
especially in these nervy moments so he
needs to get past Foria he needs to go
past lasic not going to be
easy it's going to be a fun fun battle
we hope that you're all ready for this
one because we're ready to go and what
action we saw yesterday in the losers
bracket and of course in the big Winners
final as the 17-year-old Dennis lvic
took on Magnus Carlson it was full on
drama take a
look four heavy weights in the losers
bracket have to fight it out they're on
their lost life this is a winning end
game at this stage for white in fact
fuja wins by resignation fua he survives
Jose Martinez his time in the chestle
Masters is done it's critical for FV to
play this move because if you were to
move up with your king which he does did
you see Nomi lean back with surpris that
he look he feels that he's got a second
life now Queen G6 would be Checkmate he
walked into a meeting net oh my gosh and
Vladimir fed have so close unbelievable
armaggon Magnus cursing his luck here he
knows Dennis has done perfectly and he's
about to lose with white Magnus this
nearly never happens the pawn drops
Dennis takes a historic Victory and the
white king might get checkmated be
careful here a queen trade what an offer
and it's a draw so it was brilliant by
Dennis LZ apparently this is a hold but
not after that moveie he had to play B5
a moment ago now it's too slow but in
the end Magnus Carlson's end game
technique prevailed Magnus Carlon go
into the grand final of the chessel
Masters it was a fantastic day of Chess
and we started with the losers bracket
with alira fuja taking on Jose Martinez
but for Jose Martinez the Cinderella
story comes to an end he had a fantastic
performance in the PLS at the start we
finally getting knocked out by alira and
we see Robert an incredible L high
accuracy by both these players and that
does tell the story of that match ala he
was just a little bit more accurate when
it counted Jose was in time trouble he
had a difficult end game to defend and
it was aliv Zera the youngster who now
plays for France he is able to survive
in advance and that's why he's in today
against yand
pishi and Al Resa fuja will have to
bring his aame today as he takes on the
two times World Championship Challenger
yanomi who also had a close call in his
match yesterday against Vladimir fedos
he won game one but then made a massive
blunder at the very end in game two with
sof FV bouncing back and then David it
was an absolute Topsy Derby
Armageddon right very different type of
match to the other one here we see the
accuracy level still high but not by
these top players high standards 84.9 %
accuracy only for npom nesi that shows
hero dis luck it also highlights the
nature of the play both players throwing
everything at each other and ultimately
two blunders a piece there were mistakes
it was wild it was wonderful at times
but Yan pomi his nerves held up stronger
and uh he will be aiming to play a bit
better today but he will gain confidence
from the fact he's still here despite
not yet being in Top Gear not yet in top
form so uh will that Journey continue
that's the big question
Yi has nerves as Steel in those
Armageddon first taking down Maxim
vasher lra in a tense battle and then
yesterday prevailing against the
Vladimir fedos today taking on alira
fuja it's going to be a big battle
because when I think of these two
players I feel their styles are so
similar both of them aggressive
intuitively attacking players combative
by Nature KN The Backs down both speed
monsters
what can we say about this matchup
Robert and where do you see this being
the decisive what will be the decisive
Factor here I think we're about to get a
roller coaster ride because as you said
Tanya they do have some similarities and
those similarities revolve around their
tactical style they may play openings
that are ferocious they want to throw
everything at the other but they need to
hit that break pedal at times and that
has been a struggle for both of these
two throughout their careers of course
Yan the more experienced of the two
players but all ra for
as we saw in classical chest in T Steel
he can beat the best in the world but he
can also slip when he doesn't hit that
break and it will be a best of two
Davids so very little margin for error
and there we see their pregame preview
for Ali RZA he's made more appearances
in the Champions Chester is experience
in this format going to be a
factor well be Alara is an expert in
online chess and look at the stats there
so similar not that much between them in
terms of chess.com rapid rating feed day
rating and even the head-to-head eight
wins to six in the pom she's favor is
very close this will come down uh in a
clash with two players with the highest
possible ceilings uh who are both just
fantastic players it will come down to
who handles the and um I would say npom
maybe slightly better in the opening
phase with that world championship
experience behind him but alaza is a
speed demon so close to call I think
we're just going to have to sit back and
enjoy the chess on
show it's going to be entertainment for
us but for these two players it is a big
big fight it is the fight to make it to
play against Dennis lazic to try and get
that spot into the grand final tour
points on the line there's big money on
the line and of course the big golden
ticket to the season and final as well
the pressure is high and Robert David
said it's going to be Yan I said it's
going to be ala you've got to break the
tie for us well you know who I think now
it's Dennis lavic he does have the buy
into the next round and I actually think
Dennis has been playing Amazing chess he
took down Magnus yesterday we have to
wait until later in the day to see him
go at it but between ala and Jan I'm
gonna go with Magnus Carlson not to win
the match but what he said yesterday he
said ala felt like the favorite to him
I'm gonna agree and I think that Yan he
was shaky yesterday he was shaky in the
earlier matches as well so Ali Raza will
be my pick to go through
and what do you guys think what are the
chances that this match goes to the wire
that we get an armagedon here
David I think if we got Armageddon it
might be after a couple of roller
coaster battles a bit of a comeback from
one of the sides I don't really see this
uh being too Bard draws and straight to
the decider I think if we do get an
Armageddon which would be fun to watch
then it might be after some blood has
already been spilled I'm rooting for an
Armageddon I just love the intensity of
playing without increment just the
tension and the nerves that we see so
perhaps we might have more of that uh
today coming up and as we Edge closer to
the Finish Line the first event of the
Champions chestar season 24 the
chessable Masters the finish line is in
sight the big thing for all of us to
remember is that this season there are
four events four winners will qualify to
season and final we've had a different
time format 10 plus two there have been
more changes and to explain and break it
down break all of that down for us we've
got Danny telling us how it's
done the year-long Champions chess tour
consists of four main online events and
one live final each event will begin
with a playin tournament open to all
Grand Masters and top finishers from
qualifying events 69 players from the
playin will be joined on the second day
by the four qualifiers from the previous
Tour event match play with 73 players
will then determine placement across all
three divisions division play then
commences with 6 days of Double
Elimination Brackets the last player
standing are your winners the winner of
division 1 qualifies directly to the CCT
finals the winner of division 2 secures
a spot in division 1 at the next Tour
event while the winner of division 3 is
guaranteed at least a spot in division 2
in each event players also ACR points
for the season long leaderboard the
final standings will decide who joins
our division one winners at the year end
CCT live finals each regular season
event will feature a whopping
$300,000 prize pool while the final
eight players will battle it out for
their part in half a million dollar in
prizes at the final that's $1.7 million
up for grabs in the 20124 Champions
chess tour so tune in and watch all the
action as the best chess players in the
world compete to be crowned the next CCT
Champion just a few seconds for now we
will have the first moves between Yana
pesi and alira fuja in their best of two
very little margin for errors and before
they kick off I want to talk about the
opening approach by these two players
Robert what are we expecting each of
them gets only one white what is going
to be their strategy coming into this
match
I feel like I expect the unexpected in
particular when it comes to Yan Nai
he'll throw the king's gabit out there
he'll Trot out some main lines but then
also some Sidelines so for Jan I really
don't know what's going to come from him
and same holds true for Ali Rea they're
both wild
cards I'm actually going to predict that
one of them might start a bit more
solidly that will be alera fuja um when
he has black he has shown a willingness
to just set up stall and just just try
to lock the game down with white I
totally agree with Robert he's going to
go all in he's going to try something a
bit more special but I feel that Alla
with black he's shown a different side
to him these days he's still young of
course he's trying to find a new gear
and that could be key who strikes with
the white pieces who gets onto the front
foot first but there we see Alara not
yet at the board there we go sitting
down he looks ready to
fight we can see the fair play cameras
behind the player as well here ready to
fight a fight is what we are going to
get between these two I'd love to see a
king's Gambit on the board not going to
lie that's going to be exciting but
we've seen the king's Gambit get a bit
demolished uh over the last couple of
weeks in certain games at the top level
so maybe it's too much on the line to
play the Kings Gambit but it's
definitely going to be a fun one if he
does go for it when it comes to these
time scrambles when it comes to the
mouse skills when it comes to speed
chess who in the chessable Masters out
of these two has shown better control on
nerves and better form
David it's tough to call I mean uh both
of them have been shown inconsistency at
times I would say if it's pure time
scramble where it's just seconds left
then alaza not too many can get past him
match his level of speed and confidence
and trickery uh when the clocks are
ticking but um yeah in general Yan yeah
I think his clock handling also been a
bit patchy at times so really tough one
to call um what about you Robert yeah
I'm with you we saw Al fua in the bullet
Chess Championship we know how capable
he is and for yand pami it has felt a
bit shaky even getting through to this
stage by taking down Vladimir fedosov
there was quite a bit of Fortune he did
have the upper hand he won fed's Queen
but that final position just before he
won The Rook it was actually FV who
should have had a draw in hand so I
think yand pomi he's counting His
blessings it's a new day and it's a new
opponent but they get no less fierce
yeah Nei back with the Barca Jersey but
no Cataline on the board starts with the
Kings Pawn opening E4 played the Spanish
and we have a Berlin anyone
surprised not too surprised I did
mention that ala FIA has been employing
the Berlin a lot lately uh I'm pleased
though I'm pleasantly surprised to see
Yan pishi not enter the Berlin endgame
or any forc drawing lines this one is
promising to be a tense middle game
battle there's been a trade of one set
of pieces white lights Bishop the
Spanish Bishop trading off for a black
knight damaging the black pawn structure
slightly and now the game will take a
slower maneuvering uh kind of nature but
um yeah Robert it looks like Al are
trying to be solid at this early stage
yet he's the first one to think it's
funny because this is Mainline Theory
but there are different options he
brings his Queen out to D6 some players
like to slide their Bishop back to
defend this Pawn on E5 others will
Retreat their Knight back to D7 because
you want to create a pawn chain but this
queen move up to D6 it walks into the
line of fire wow speaking of firing B4
Tanya I don't think I've seen this
before this is a pawn sacrifice going
after the black Bishop but that Bishop
can just take the
pawn is this a novelty before I've never
seen it before Robert's not seen it
before David are you at all familiar
with this Pawn sacrifice and what
happens if black asy gets greedy we're
about to find out we're finding out the
proof in the the e think how does it
work you got to take up the challenge
essentially proofing the pudding is the
eating that's it thank you Robert uh
essentially you have to grab material if
you want to refute your opponent's idea
instead of timidly retreating ala says
yes I'm taking that pawn and um I can
confess I have studied this position
before I can't remember exactly how the
line goes but essentially it's long it's
forcing and uh black is forced
essentially to find some really creative
defenses just to cling on and survive so
I really love this idea by yand pomi I
believe it's been played in the past by
the likes of jeul mad French Grandmaster
and ala he's been caught off guard
exclamation mark from this last move it
reminds me Robert of a Evans Gambit but
in the Spanish opening why just throwing
away for a pawn for a couple of tempo it
makes perfect sense once I see it on the
board I would be too afraid to give a
pawn as Yana pom just did and Al is in
for a think but I do believe the bishop
has slide in this direction the downside
of going to A5 is it allows the white
Bishop to get out on this open diagonal
and probably prevent black from castling
anytime soon but if the bishop goes to
C5 if we can bring up an analysis board
this is a very direct plan from the
white side is that white wants to push
in the center you give away a flank Pawn
so that you could push in the center and
if black continues to take things then
you pay the full price this is a baby
Fork but it wins a knight because your
queen and Knight are both threatened you
move the queen you lose the Knight and
so in the game position after C3 the
bishop has to slide back to A5 as it
just has that wasn't mind doing but the
white Bishop it can go out to A3 and I
do think there's going to be some
trouble in Black's Camp what a line This
is Tanya I haven't seen it before but
now that I have I kind of want to play
it
myself really interesting from the start
B4 on the board I was surprised to see
it but I like it more and more and
especially the kind of opening that you
employ when your opponent has only 10
minutes on the clock to deal with all
these questions maybe in a classical
game it's a lot easier to answer these
kind of sacrifices early on but here it
forces Ali Resa to burn clock early on
and the problems are just getting
started Bishop A3 hitting that Queen
more importantly making sure Black's
King stays in the center eventually
White's knight from B1 can also land on
C4 ya D2 C4 there's a break coming up
with the idea of D4 and black still far
away from finding safety for King I am
loving the compensation already David uh
how does black react how does black get
his King to safety
here not going to be easy getting the
black king to safety is just one of the
several problems first he has to decide
how to move how to react with the black
queen the queen is hit after all you
need to S side step I believe if I
remember correctly you s side step to E6
just to keep your Central Pawn intact
the only safe Square for the black queen
to defend the e Square um but I think
your points about the clock Tanya that
might be the most important thing right
now already 2 and a half minutes down on
the clock fua he's going to have to move
the queen later he's going to have to
hope potentially that he can even Castle
Queens side looks like you're castling
into the attack castling into the eye of
uh the firing line but um essentially
there's no other safe haven for that
King and um all these questions are
going to keep arising how to defend how
to react to the opponent's threats for
I'm already worried at that about that
clock time 6 minutes and it's only just
starting Yan clearly within his homework
this is what we talked about world
championship preparation he's dig he's
uh guaranteed to have dug deep here and
uh studied all the intricacies Quint E6
indeed on the board and uh Robert we're
expecting either the center to blow open
or white to just keep improving pieces
keep developing yeah Knight to D2 up to
C4 which was one of Tanya's main ideas
and it's a perfectly a good developing
try but is it worth giving up a second
Pawn because if you move your knight out
you no longer defend this Pawn on C3 I'm
curious how Yan continues I'm also
noting that he has slowed down so he
sacrificed a pawn now he's spending some
time so how much Theory does he have
here ala clearly on his own and Yan
playing a top move I see that the engine
has not changed its evaluation Queen A4
this bishop can go back to B6 or I guess
you could play Pawn to B6 but then that
Bishop on A5 is really stuck and I feel
like white can go after it later so
difficult choices here for black with B6
also Knight takes E5 becomes an idea
with the c six Pawn being loose all of a
sudden oh I do not envy the task for ala
fua I would quickly try to play Bishop
B6 but I don't know how I'm going to
Castle as the king is stuck in the
center this bishop on A3 such a nasty
piece making sure the king can't Castle
through C I worry for Ali reaza here
that's a really nice tactic that you
spotted especially after B6 that the
queen on E6 is overloaded and uh Yan's
last move Queen to A4 also clearly shows
why alira could not have blocked the
attack from that Bishop on A3 to the
queen on D6 with the move C5 earlier on
because you really want to Castle but C5
would have landed Queen to A4 with a
check winning the bishop on A5 wow and
look at that he walks into the tactics
that you've been talking about Robert B6
on the board Queen is overloaded on E6
Knight takes pawn it would not only
neutralize the material that's been
given not only recapturing the pawn puts
pressure on C6 black king still in the
center and Yan he smells blood right now
David look at her you're right look at
that camera he was frowning for a moment
he was surprised clearly visibly uh by
that last move it looks like a kind of
Elementary blunder but of course fua has
a deeper plan um yam just trying to
figure that out look at him drowning on
the camera I'm trying to figure it out
what is the idea Knight takes E5 looks
automatic regaining the material balance
but also continuing the threats I guess
black might want to move the light
Square push out the way there we go ala
immediately does that and the black king
is almost ready to Castle
queenside problems here though still
persist Robert the black Dart Square
Bishop lacking squares a point you
highlighted earlier still doesn't look
safe and now he's not even suffering for
anything he's not even a pawn up anymore
Knight C four it would be the move I'm
playing in bullet chest this bishop has
nowhere to go and I'm going to take it
on the next turn and I guess the engine
perhaps ala does not mind the completely
shattered Pawn structure that will arise
after this Knight takes on A5 and once
this B Pawn takes you have two sets of
double isolated pawns on the queen side
and yet black does feel quite
coordinated with the queenside castle
coming a rook that lands on d8 will put
pressure on this loose Pawn on D3 white
isn't fully developed I think we're
seeing all of this you have to take on
A5 for white at some point and look at
this Pawn structure this is what I'm
talking about double isolated pawns oh
it looks atrocious and yet this Rook on
d8 that is getting the green light
because it hits this D3 Pawn which
protects this E4 Pawn could White's
position fall apart
Tanya it's hard for me to imagine that
happening I mean I'm looking at the
board right now and I am loving position
that Queen on A4 eyeing the A5 A7 Pawn
which you can't you don't even have to
necessarily pick up right now you can
first defend your D3 pawn and then start
targeting this these two pawns on the a
file the Bishop from A3 could land on C5
at some moment putting more pressure on
A7 the only thing the only thing that
I'd love white to have is to improve and
develop the pieces on the queen side
give white two moves that Knight lands
on C4 wire D2 and it feels like it would
be close to game over the bishop on B7
is long-term block not only by his own
Pawn on C6 but by the pawn on e4 as well
I think black is really far away David
from creating attack against White's
King while white already has open lines
on the queen side to start directing
play on Black's King what do you think
is is Black's position compensation
worth it here for these doubled
pawns uh I'm going to have to agree with
you Tanya my eyes here I can't get past
the kind of Aesthetics of the position
how ugly that black PA structurers
actually until this last move I was
going to ask you Robert to do one of
your favorite things uh if the white
porn were back on C2 rather than on C3 a
beautiful porn chain uh White would just
have everything protected and it would
just be game over white would have no
weaknesses um it's unfortunate that Yan
has to retreat with the White Queen
because as Tanya mentioned the White
Queen wanted to get uh kind of hungry
there and start grabbing eating up these
black pawns But ultimately he knows
longterm he's doing very well here and
actually this is quite a classy move I
feel Queen to C2 not getting impatient
knowing that you have the better
structure and as T points out the Knight
is hopping the White Knight to Moose if
you get to D2 B3 or anywhere into the
black position and it's just game over
so Robert haera four minutes now two
minutes down on the clock the urgency of
the position do you see him saving this
urgency is the operative word here that
he needs to act fast as you're both are
pointing out that if white just gets a
few moves maybe Pawn to F3 just to
ensure that the e Pawn is defended and
even then Pawn to D4 black is just toast
because the white pieces will just hop
around and black cannot create Pawn
tension because all of these pawns are
isolated if this Pawn were back on B6
we'd be singing a different tune but
with the pawn on A5 it looks terrible C5
won't be so attractive uh so I I don't
really see easily how black goes after
those pawns but you need to probably
flick in a move like C5 at some point
because Bishop A6 it's a one move threat
against the D3 Pawn but white will push
this Pawn to C4 with a bishop on A6
saying you're not getting any access in
fact you actually are making your king
side or the queen side in this case but
that's where the black king is even less
safe so I don't like the look of this he
does Play Bishop A6 I think C4 is
mandatory but oh that's not even my
highlight that's the blue arrow telling
us an only move from the white side but
this D3 Pawn is a long-term Target so I
kind of feel like I'm agreeing with you
I still feel like Oliva has some outside
chances and wait a second is that a
PA it definitely looks like one the pawn
on D3 is spinned Rook D1 hanging you
can't really capture the Knight back on
e4 and maybe ala just has to snap it up
for whether white has compensation or
not Yan will have to prove it right now
ala's under three minutes he needs to
start moving he needs to speed things up
right now if he doesn't grab material
there's very little to play for and he
does it Knight takes Pawn I'm expecting
white to develop the Knight could not
have taken the Knight on e4 Queen into
Rook was hanging not just The Rook you
lose your king as well it's a Checkmate
I still think there's a lot of
compensation for this Pawn that's been
sacrificed A5 is hanging well g7's
hanging but I'm not sure if you really
ever want to pick up that pawn and open
the G line might not be a good idea I'm
expecting white to continue bringing the
Rook into activity right now Rook to B1
line up on the open b line opposite
color Bishops it's all about the attack
on your opponent's king
David yeah and it's just about whether
Yan ponesi can generate that attack
against the black king
um I was just reminded of that line from
the Queen's Gambit all pawns and no hope
those black pawns so ugly right now then
again opposite color Bishops do give
black the opportunity at later at later
moment to bail out if the Queens ever
disappear we'll be uh completely kind of
revising our assessment of this position
so suddenly urgency on Fu's part of
course due to the clock but this boring
boring Berlin is far from boring right
now and Yan suddenly the urgency on him
to actually Checkmate black while he has
the opportunity if he allows ala to
survive the next five moves Robert we
could really see a turnaround uh he's a
PN down after all yand pish suddenly and
I see how the turn around happens you
give black a free move in comes a rook
to E2 threatening Checkmate against the
white king and let's be clear even if
this queen somehow gets to B8 the black
king steps up to D7 and I don't see a
follow up the evaluation bar it's
getting about even the clocks they're
evening up up although yand pomi still
has a substantial lead he it was even
larger before but he has to invest time
because Black's next move is pretty
clear and yeah I could play Rook to D2
but now I'm getting passive and black
can still go on offense we're going to
see a rook lift from the black side and
I'm actually starting to prefer Black's
position earlier it looked ugly bad Pawn
structure black has a pawn ahead and has
a clearer plan so am I maybe overstating
the case Tanya or are you starting to
come on to my side which is saying that
all rais this position there is some
hope
here I never thought I would say this
given the start of this position but I
completely see all your points The Rook
lift is incoming whether to the second
rank or the sixth rank to move towards
the king side it looks like danger but I
just want to push a little bit on this
line that you were pointing out I don't
think that white should fall back to B2
because the D3 Pawn will fall I think
after the queen goes to B2 black can
take on D3 you give a check like you
pointed out the king is actually pretty
Prett safe on D7 but Robert your other
line that you were earlier looking at
that if Black's Rook was to get to E2 I
think there is a key defensive resource
in White's position imagine white goes
Queen B3 Rook to E2 I give a check on B8
let's have that on the board and I
actually think that white can snap up
this Pawn on
A7 and the bar creeps up and it looks
like things are under control and like
you're pointing out that from A7 I'm not
only hitting that Bishop on A6 but I'm
actually defending the pawn on F2 so I'm
just wondering David if white can just
start going on the offense and not be
too scared about rukie to here Tanya I
think he could have done and he should
have done because if we go back to the
game instead Yan pomi plays a real
passive move look at him on the camera
shaking his head he knows this is
turning and uh as soon as you start
stepping back with your pieces you know
instinctively the momentum turns as well
the white Bishop is aiming to sit on a
nice pretty square like E3 but will you
get that time will you get that luxury
black first has a move still two minutes
for FIA so not easy but even a move such
as Queen to E5 forcing the Queens off
pretty much I'm looking at the white
back rank I don't think uh npom Nishi
can continue There we go the most
natural move I don't think he can
continue being ambitious in this game I
think now it's all about actually uh
kind of backpedaling and trying to
secure a draw he's a pawn down after all
and again on the camera he was dancing
around with his head there he knows
Robert he knows this has g a bit wrong
and there is x marks the spot for a miss
but I'm going to disagree with the
engine I think that some of the ways to
play for in a black Advantage are not
realistic for human players because it's
the black king that looked like it was
under attack and as you point out a long
time ago without Queens on the board the
black King's in no danger the pawn
structure is ugly but let's not forget
that white also has a pawn that needs to
have a caretaker so this Pawn on D3 it's
going to keep Black's White's Rooks
stuck in place white has shut down a lot
of Black's plans and black has shut down
a lot of white SLS by the way Bishop F4
this looks like a really risky move to
play what is the response after Bishop
F4 Rook V6 because of back rank
oh so sneaky fuja he's the trickster one
minute something on his clock but he
finds such devilish tactics like that
wow that's just tempting the opponent
provoking the opponent look like a
beginner's blunder again but that skewer
doesn't quite pay off for white Tanya
you agree this is turning who do you
think is the favorite now I'm so
impressed with this Rook D6 bullet Beast
fuja just finding these tactics with a
minute on the clock and I was on the
edge earlier David but now I think I am
moving towards Robert's side about this
position the evaluation of this position
black has an extra Pawn the Rooks are
extremely active the D3 Pawn a constant
Target opposite color Bishops give black
not only a safety net but also always
that Bishop can fall back to B7 and
start targeting White's King side as
well and this last move alira wants to
trade on his terms he wants his Pawn
structure to get better which is why Yan
refuses he's not going to take on B6 and
allow Ali Resa to improve his Pawn
structure the bishop falls back it just
feels that black has easier moves to
make at some point the kingside pawns
can start advancing uh going up the
board trying to create a weakness G5 G4
ideas once it's defended I'm really
liking black here David
I've got to agree I think with two or
three extra minutes on his clock fuia
would be a huge favorite here but the
clock ticking down we might just get an
answer to our question about who handles
time pressure better because we're
reaching that stage and look at the big
threats that are appearing suddenly
white King Pawn in front of it was
attacked and uh okay it's hanging by a
thread for the white king side right now
but Yan he's hoping that everything
holds together and he's looking to the
other flank where those weak black pawns
finally might just start dropping off uh
Robert here does fuia have to go passive
or does he continue with this active
vein of play if fuia can get two moves
at once Pawn to F4 is winning for black
and the reason why this bishop on B7 it
was a horrible piece for most of the
game now it has the full length of the
diagonal so if black can land a back
rank check it won't just be check it
will be Checkmate because once The Rook
ifoc coulds jump over and here's the big
threat Rook B1 the king would have to go
and then the Rook would land behind the
king with Checkmate thanks to the full
scope of the diagonal from this bishop
so watch out if you're yanomi I know
this black Rook went back and forth but
there's so many weak squares and a
bishop can plant itself on F3 at any
moment I fear for the white king which
is such a strange thing to say
considering earlier on it was the black
king in danger so I prefer all's
position still although Jan is doing
everything right to keep the
balance yeah Yan has managed to sorry
David keep the balance I just want to
make one point that it was so
instructive that alira actually provoked
the move G2 to G3 before returning with
the Rook actually making that Bishop on
B7 an absolute moner monster making sure
that he has this F3 stronghold in
White's Camp so really instructive there
David to provoke pawn moves to provoke
weaknesses in the
position know uh I mean I get the
impression here fuja he's just playing
for one move traps one move tactics
every move he's creating a threat and
actually napesi he's an only move
territory already we see the blue arrow
there on the board Pawn to H4 might be
the only way to save it because suddenly
there's a big checkmating idea in the
position if black gets one more move to
play G5 suddenly there's a sacrifice in
the air and uh oh he plays it he guards
on the dark squares now he's trying to
set up a fortress on that color complex
but uh yeah that black Rook on the sixth
rank was almost ready to swing on over
um I think Yan he's guarding against the
threats it's suddenly under 20 seconds
for rja the problem with creating
threats like this is you're kind of
committing suddenly the black Rook on H5
is totally stuck the other Rook on the
other flank totally stuck again it could
be turning because Fu's committed to
this activity when maybe he didn't have
the luxury to do so suddenly yand pomi
he's going for those weak porns and it's
just a race Black's attack versus white
just hoovering up moing up vacuuming up
those pawns uh Robert chaos has been
enacted I would rather have yap's time
but ala F's King whoa G4 look at uh Yan
right here the pawn actually can take
because there's a G3 check look at this
vision from Ali reaza it looked
impossible you give up a rook that was a
brilliant choice because otherwise white
would have had the edge now we have an
opposite colored Bishop position with
Rooks on the board and black don't
forget is up a pawn so Tanya still
outside chances for ala because of this
outside pass Pawn super defense and
resource and offense by both these
players it almost felt like ala missed
G4 and then Yan miss that the G4 Pawn
can be captured by alas spawn giving
this tactic of G3 check keeping the
balance by regaining that rook and now
the position that we have black is still
up a pawn but with the Rook defending
that A5 Pawn all the pawns disconnected
86 being a weakness I think this game is
heading towards a draw David towards a
draw maybe but Alara with six seconds
he's still got to keep up the pace
yesterday we saw Magnus Carlson lose on
time two second increment isn't much so
he still has to keep his guard up but
he's doing everything right here with
black uh to stay safe suddenly the white
Rook is the one that's slightly
misplaced offside um I wouldn't be
surprised actually all three results
still possible draw yes the most likely
but ala creating threats hitting pawns
uh this is wow really not great for the
nerves 5 Seconds every move he's making
the bishop Bishop oh my goodness he had
to give it up to get a pass Pawn if
black can get rid of White's two pawns
here even though white will have an
extra Bishop drawing chances but that
was a blunder and a great find from Yan
pami who now has a nearly winning
Advantage according to the computer but
he needs to keep this one Pawn alive
otherwise it might be a rook Bishop
versus Rook which is a theoretical draw
so D6 was the only move you need to keep
this Pawn guarded ala will do everything
to try to win it but with it being on a
dark Square the bishop will defend it
the players playing on seconds both
players under 10 seconds it's still a
bit tricky to convert David really
tricky watch out for those black pawns
that are running the black Rook often
aiming to deliver some checks or swap
off for the white Rook but White's Rook
is coming now with a check the pawn
promotes on a dart Square can he force
it through Brute Force it's a porn race
Robert who's going to make a queen first
apparently both players are making
mistakes The Rook comes back to A7
defending and attacking and look at this
position both sides could blunder at any
turn and watch out there was a skewer on
the seventh rank the king steps out I
think that ala now is feeling more
confident but look at him he stared up
at the clock try to make sure that he
has enough time left to execute his
plan Black's porn is one square away
from touchdown he's taking big risks
here in Nomi to try and win this game
but black is on the brink of making a
new Queen surely now is the time to bail
out to safety we might see a repetition
in this position repeating itself but
Yan plays for the win yet again oh he's
taking risks now the where is the win
you can't defend the a pawn from
queening he's giving up his own strong
Pawn to come back with the Rook but this
is Rook Bishop versus
Rook oh my goodness this game is just
getting started everybody because if
you're Yap pami you play it out forever
you try to do what Vladimir fedos SE of
did against Magnus Carlson you need to
get this pawn and then Force black on
the defense so David in this kind of end
game we know theoretically it should be
a draw in fact to the left of the board
it says TB in the middle table based
draw but can't ala hold this with mere
seconds on his clock it's not going to
be easy that black porn now sits on a
dark Square it should be able it should
be possible even to surround that pawn a
bit later and as we saw Magnus Carson
even lost on time in this end game
finding struggling to find the defense
and look at this the pawn about to land
but it gets blocked and it will surely
get captured at some point um I still
believe in fua his clock look at it 10
seconds now he's gaining time he's
pre-moving he's such a speed demon but
uh
Robert I still feel there's going to be
chances like you said it's just starting
we might see 50 more moves now that that
pawn has disappeared and the counter
starts this is move 89 and uh still a
long long way to go before alera is able
to save this game Robert Tanya we need
to predict what do we think is he going
to hold with 14 seconds on a draw I am
predicting an alz a hold here I think he
will do this what a fine it was by him
to even save to even manage to get get
it to this position I think he's got it
in him uh Robert to to manage to hold
this one and save the draw he's got 15
seconds left if he had five seconds I
would still think that he has it in him
because he's putting his Rook on the
light squares this is key everyone you
want to keep your Rook on the opposite
color of your opponent's Bishop he keeps
going the light squares he tries to
offer a trade of Rooks King and Bishop
versus King for a newer members of the
audience that is a draw so a rook Trade
It favors black and with a two second
increment every single move that's play
it grows your time on the clock that's
what Ali Raza is counting on look at
this two squares away any check the king
could slide and protect that Rook so I'm
I'm thinking this should be a draw
especially by how quickly aliv re is
playing Ground Masters in the world
they've practiced this they've studied
this they spent dozens maybe even
hundreds of hours playing rook and
Bishop versus Rook just to learn the
drawing motifs even then it's difficult
impossible to memorize specific uh
specific moves of course you just have
to know the setup and look how fua he's
using something we call the third rank
defense where just a couple of lines
away from being forced into the corner
he's able to set up this blockade on the
light squares on the opposite color
complex to his opponent's Bishop uh but
if the black king gets pushed to the
edge that's when the trouble might start
he's done everything right so far though
and uh still I'm just looking at the
move counter still 25 moves or so before
the 50 move roll so he's survived this
long if he survives as long uh kind of
he's halfway if he continues to do this
he's got the draw in the bank it's
getting close but still in the pomine
not quite finding the breakr this is
frustrating Rob it's definitely
frustrating but it's great defense from
fuja as David's been saying if the black
king is kicked to the side of the board
the boundary can only help white and now
that the rook and the King for black are
separated Yan may feel like he has some
chances and only if he cuts the king off
but look at Aliva he puts his Rook right
back on the light square and that means
that it's hard harder and harder to get
this King to the rim Tanya this is great
defense from Ala but still some time
left for Jan to get that King to where
he needed to be incredibly instructive
exactly 20 moves left for Yan and naishi
to make progress where do you get the
king you get it to the edge of the board
he's managed to separate the king in The
Rook but the way fuja is playing the way
he's held that third rank defense it's
clear that he knows how to hold this
position but there's still going to be a
moment where he'll have to make those
accurate moves and now with the King and
Rook separated David this is the other
defensive structure in these
positions he's been forced one row back
but now it's the second rank defense
where black on his own second rank here
the seventh from White's point of view
he's holding the line he's not allowing
any checks and uh if the white bishop
ever tries to move he'll kick the white
king away he's doing perfectly this is
one to study for everyone at home this
is a defensive Master Class still yand
pomi unable to break through still has
to be careful fua but he's edging ever
closer now only a few moves left five
more moves I believe and we will see
this game declared draw so impressive
Robert this is great defense Perfect
Defense from fuja continuing to keep the
king that was what was that from Yan he
gave away his rook and now it's Ali RZA
who could play for the win it's still a
draw everybody but that was ridiculous
gosh that has to be a m slip to be what
oh my God and now it's a 50 move counter
and it's y Bishi who has to make it
through that of course the defensive
resource is that you put your King on
the corner which is the opposite color
of your own Bishop where Yan is already
but it's ala who's trying for a win now
David the game that never ends it's a
real Marathon here clearly npom she
loves playing chess so much that he
wanted to entertain us with another 50
moves remember rook and Bishop versus
Rook was a draw this is also a draw uh
arguably even easier but still a lot of
work to do to prove it there's going to
be checkmating ideas against the white
king the problem is the black king can
never obtain the opposition and sit
opposite the white king and uh therefore
there's always one Escape square
but NPI confidently building up time
here 40 seconds left there's still a
chance he might blunder it's still
possible to go wrong these top players
finally it's a draw Robert did you see
that he gave away his Rook so a bit of
humor between these two Yi he did have
the upper hand once ala lost his Bishop
he trapped his own piece but a draw
feels like the fair result but ton what
a fight that was between these two from
start to finish from the opening in a
Berlin finding this idea playing it out
sacrificing the PA four piece activity
an completely crazy position with
opposite side castling both players
going for each other's King but amazing
defensive resource saw them hold a
balance things got crazy in the time
scramble eventually ends in a draw with
some drama at the end loved every bit of
it we've got their final rapid game
coming up David this one is exactly how
you predicted it would be a very close
fight close fight it could have gone
either way ultimately Nomi Started Hot
started strong with a opening bomb but
fuia defended resolutely got some
chances himself but had to defend in the
end after getting his Bishop trapped
roller coaster could have gone either
way and uh I think actually fua the
happier of the two Robert he drew with
the black pieces how could he not be the
happier of the two and they did have
some Smiles on their faces because there
was that slip from Yan and then Al said
you know you have this under control you
know the theoretical draw so I don't
want to play this out anymore but Tanya
I mean that game I think it probably
shakes players even if ala got the draw
with black that's the desired result it
wasn't a solid draw it was a rocky road
there I mean their sty of play it's
never going to be a solid draw we're
always going to have entertainment on
the board we're always going to have
fire on the board when You' got Yan and
Ali Resa playing the end was really
dramatic with that Mouse slip one pair
is up material then the other one is and
then we see finally it does end in a
draw it's going to be a fun fight that's
for sure now we saw Ali RZA go in with a
solid Berlin approach out of the opening
this game he starts with white what are
we expecting from Yan how does he keep
things under control with black in this
one David like he's trying to figure it
out as well just munching away snacking
up and coming up with an opening
strategy a bit of a shake of the head
there from fuja may be frustrated that
he was on the back foot for most of that
game but uh yeah Yan if he employs his
world championship repertoire he might
start with the Petro defense that will
be the ultimate sign of respect to fua
and that would indicate that yanan's
happy with the draw wants to go to
Armageddon but even that I mean the
players have to be thinking kind of two
three steps ahead who in the Armageddon
will I be the favorite what color do I
want there um yeah I mean like you said
Tanya no boring draws here that was 162
moves and uh that's my favorite type of
Chess but the players are going to be
feeling the heat the uh the exhaustion
already so much tension this game could
be the end of the road for one of these
two players it is the final rapid game
Robert what are you expecting are you
expecting more cautious Safety First
approach or will one of them want to
take this want to go on L take the risks
for this to be the decisive game
cautious is a foreign word to both of
these players they seem to give it their
all each and every game they're throwing
pieces at one another so throw caution
to the wind let's get another fight I
don't know what Ali re is going to
choose from the white side and we'll see
what preparation yanomi has in store
because we should give credit where it's
due Jan played an excellent opening and
he caught ala by
surprise it caught ala by surprise RIS
but also impressive how ala took his
time in the opening and was able to
handle that pressure was able to combat
all those uh attacking tactical ideas uh
by Yan and talking about attacking
tactical ideas we've got a jababa London
David does this surprise you yes and no
Alara actually started with one Knight
to C3 a really rare move at the top
level but the last time he played it was
against yanomi at the tataa steel
Masters where using the DAV
by transposition he actually wiped Yan
off the board in under 30 moves so he
has great experiences from the wh side
fuja against Yan in recent history but
of course when you repeat the same
opening your opponent will have studied
it and Yan mixes up his uh or kind of
switches up his openings here he doesn't
employ the same variation he did and wow
look at this npom nesi uh kind of giving
a frown there trademark facial
expression from him but aler is going
for fire on the board G for go that g
Pawn launching forward and uh big
threats already on the board Robert this
is again shaping up to be a big big
fight and look at Yan he decides to
ignore it for now by creating threats of
his own on the B2 pawn and yes this G5
move it looks annoying you're kicking
the night but you may also welcome it
into the center And Trades they they
don't necessarily hurt black it's white
who is lacking in development because
you're pushing pawns instead of
developing pieces so now ala on the
clock doesn't seem particularly familiar
with this position Tanya sometimes these
opening tricks and traps you may trick
yourself because when your opponent just
plays quite standard chess you may have
created some holes and weaknesses in
your own
camp and it is a bit uh it surprises me
that alira played G4 we were excited to
see this move and then Queen B6 a
natural looking developing move you're
attacking the B2 Pawn you get your queen
to to a square where it eventually does
land up very often in these lines and
then ala takes a long think right now it
feels like he came up with a surprise
but then he surprised himself he finally
chooses a move that defense B2 but to me
Rook B1 is a bit of an ugly move you've
already played G4 your king isn't going
to Castle on the shot side and now with
Rook B1 you take away a longside
queenside longside queenside a longterm
queenside Castle as well from your king
I'm not very sure about White's position
right now I think Yan should be happy
with
this he already play the jaava London
one of the most aggressive openings out
there shout out to our friend James KY
but uh yeah Rook to B1 is not an
aggressive move so it's not in the
spirit of the position I agree with you
Tanya it feels it smells Wrong Feels
inconsistent at the very least White's
move Rook to B1 now white will never
Castle Queen side therefore uh the white
king is kind of caught in two minds
where's it going to end up you've
committed you've opened up your own King
side already um yeah I don't like it at
all for fuja especially the time usage
it feels like npom yet again again just
like the previous game has won the
opening battle nothing kind of uh
substantial of course it's not winning
for either side but psychologically fu
is on the back foot yet again Nomi with
a Time advantage and I think that will
only grow Robert um already no obvious
moves for white well we talking about
psychology we understand the Temptation
from Ala to repeat an opening that he
had great success with you mentioned it
David that in tata to Steel a classical
tournament ala beat Jan and it was quite
a one-sided game but players they study
from their losses they learn from their
mistakes and I feel like Yan has learned
this very well because his last move G6
it's it's not just trying to F kto his
Bishop it's anticipating that white
wants to throw a pawn forward and black
while the rim may seem dim then Black
Knight will happily step to H5 to attack
this bishop on F4 so alza now continues
with development rather than pressing
forward with his pawns I feel like this
isn't like continuity between his moves
he pushes a g pawn and then slows down
black attacks him on the queen side so
he has to move his rook and disallow
himself from castling in that direction
I just don't like the way that this
opening is gone but maybe I'm
overstating the case Tanya I just feel
like Yan has played every single move
naturally and it's alza who's kind of
waffling about that's exactly what it
feels right right from the black side
Yan takes out the queen then fan CS the
bishop finds a nice post for that Bishop
now gone Castle meanwhile White's Rook
on B1 seems a little misplaced the H3 G4
can become long-term targets maybe
someday black will strike with H5 asking
questions on the king side an idea that
you have to constantly watch out for the
Black Knight might jump to E4 posing
more questions in the center it just
feels like this opening approach by ala
has actually worked out really well for
Yan the point that you made earlier
about them having played in tataa steel
that has also a psychological effect
because yes your opponent's prepared in
this case Yan has prepared this line but
actually at the back of his mind he also
knows that he had a bad result so it's
also a bit of a mind game by Ala in this
one maybe it hasn't turned out the way
he had hoped for David yeah it
definitely didn't turn out the way he'd
hoped for he's now a minute down on the
clock with white still uncared a bit of
a mirror image the previous game Black's
King was stuck unable to Castle King's
side because of a bishop piercing down a
diagonal now it's the black queen
stopping using x-ray to stop the white
king from castling Tanya you mentioned
the kind of backdrop of the Tata steel
Masters where ala struck now they're
about to play the candidates tournament
in a couple of months uh it feels like
there's uh kind of this real hunger to
be the one to strike to kind of assert
dominance before that potentially career
defining tournament uh in April so
Quinter D3 by alera I think that's a
good kind of change of pace for him um I
was going to try and make Robert a proud
partner in crime here by talking about
porn breaks black controlling all the PN
breaks but once the Queens are off maybe
less of a urgent Factor um but yeah it
feels like black won the opening battle
but ultimately it's still a level
position still Mutual chances
andx still long long way off of this
game a couple turns ago black received a
question mark for playing Queen to A6
which to my eyes looked like a very
natural move so you know it's difficult
position to figure out you will make
some of these slight inaccuracies it
wasn't a blunder it was just the engine
preferred a different line that may have
required a little bit more of an
adventurous Spirit but yanomi he's
playing very solidly here and yes white
has a slight pull according to the
evaluation bar also according to my eyes
now I like the presence of this bishop
on G2 I think that if black trades
Queens opening the C file can backfire
allowing White's Rooks to stare into
Black's position so I think that white
has control over more critical squares
and as David you did make me proud I
don't see the pawn breaks anymore for
black because you ever push your C Pawn
down goes your D pawn and Knight to E8
that Tanya to my eyes a nice move
trading off pieces when you feel like
you are the restricted player makes a
lot of sense you want to ease out the
pressure and you pointed out that if
black was to trade on D3 it opens up the
sea line yes it doubles the white pawns
but it those double pawns actually
control a lot of central squares which
is why Yan is not blinking first he's
not immediately rushing with the queen
trade because actually the double pawns
give white a lot of pluses in return
trading off this strong Bishop on E5
makes a lot of sense once it's gone
black can even start dreaming about a
central break with E5 which is why ala
doesn't take a decision keeps the
tension he's advancing on the queen side
he's also hinting at a potential B5
coming up next which will then Target
the base the C6 pawn and then that G2
Bishop which you highlighted just a move
ago becomes a real monster Robert wow
he's out playing Yan at this stage I
thought that a black played a very solid
open
but a few moves ago this B6 move to
potentially develop Black's light score
Bishop I could see a backfiring a pawn
chain is only as strong as its base pawn
and there's base Pawn at this mini chain
here between C6 and D5 it's easy to
collapse this chain a pawn back on B7
would probably be in Black's favor at
least something you'd prefer so E6
played to defend this Pawn on D5 give it
a second Defender here why can keep
advancing David I think the space that
Ali Raza is grabbing it's useful and it
makes Black's life very
difficult the porn structure is the
skeleton of any position and five moves
ago it was black who controlled all the
pawn braks black could have pushed a
bunch of Pawns all over the board on
either flank Suddenly It's white who has
that luxury white can push A4 white can
push H4 F4 anything E4 in the center a
bit later um so it's definitely fuja who
has the abundance of choice I'm not sure
you want choice in a rapid game you want
to trust your instincts and kind of play
by Instinct there we go G5 is one of
those uh pawn moves but yeah it's very
much turning in uh White's favor here
and I'm loving what f is doing he's
using that packing recognition B4 that's
kind of reminiscent of those minority
attacks we see in all these queen porn
openings and um yeah it's very much
pressure on yanomi to break out black is
kind of entrenched in his first two
three ranks he needs to trade pieces but
he doesn't want to do it on the
opponent's terms Tanya um are you in
agreement is it is it white here who's
uh who's making the magic happen or is
the P still solid enough thear says that
everything's fine for black but it looks
the kind of position that from a human
perspective is so hard to play because
you've got little space you know you
said pawns are the skeleton of a
position pawns are The Souls of a
position so Soul skeleton everything is
in white side right now you've got the
pawns pushing you've got more space
you've got the brakes eventually the H
Pawn can move further ahead H4 H5 ideas
opening up the hline I'm just trying to
think how does black actually free
himself and now he takes on E5 I was
about to suggest another Pawn break
maybe F6 could have been on the radar
but now with this last trade robbert
that's off the table as well there's no
F6
anymore definitely not because white has
a clamp in that direction this Knight on
C3 it belongs on F6 but there's no way
black will allow it to get there it's a
long journey but as a fan ketto Pawn
structure we often teach people you can
attack it you can develop your Rook on
its starting Square by going after the
fan ketto Pawn structure so Tanya you
sounded like you were in Mortal Kombat
for a second your soul is mine that's
exactly what ala is aiming for right now
he's just going straight for Yap Papi's
king and a queen trade doesn't entirely
help because white will have nothing to
worry about you can slide your own King
up connect your Rooks double your Rooks
and go for a Checkmate so David uh this
does not look Pleasant in the least for
yand pomi and that's why he's lashing
out here are those Pawn breaks that
we've been
discussing finally that tension is
broken it was like a staring contest and
finally it was yand poni who blinked
first as you mentioned Tanya the the
tension was just too much the prospect
of an attack against the black king was
too much and seeking counterplay very
wise choice there good tip for everyone
at home if you feel the momentum is
going against you if you feel that
you're just kind of suffering passive
not doing anything look to strike out if
you can and uh at least he's asking a
question how does fuia react as he push
this B Pawn forward as trade off on A5
does he just guard and kind of maintain
uh the kind of structure by pushing a
pawn to A3 lots of choice it's become a
more strategic position now but I'm
looking again skeleton of the position
White's light squared Bishop for now
probably more potential than its
counterpart and I still think that white
has enough control here more squares
more uh yeah more control and wow he's
just going for it robt he's still
playing for checkmate who cares about
the absence of Queens he is this is bad
for his uh skeleton for this Pawn
structure but it's great for his Rook if
this Pawn is captured because the Rook
takes on B4 and then just like a fast
car zooms over to H4 shout out to Tracy
Chapman that was an incredible
performance at the gramys uh but here
this Rook is about to land on H4 and
that is going to be painful this open H
file this King doesn't have Defenders
around it a lot of people think without
Queens on the board there won't be a
Checkmate that's not true in this case
so I like the restraint shown from Yap
pomi Bishop D7 is an excellent move
connecting his Rooks making certain that
this Rook on B1 will not easily enter
along the H file it takes a few moves
and you don't really want your king in
the center when the Black Rook is
staring down an open file and this Rook
at least for now it is delayed getting
on over to the king side wow what a move
though by Ali RI here Tanya do you like
his decision to take first the first pun
off the
board it's really interesting and you
said Mortal Kombat these two are playing
like it's Mortal Kombat right now a
black can't we capture with his own Rook
cuz the B6 Pawn is hanging which
actually might Force black to take back
with the pawn but is that a happy
decision you leave behind so many
squares not only can The Rook enter to
B7 which looks very deadly on the
seventh R but eventually even the Knight
can go from A4 to C5 and really get a
big hold in the position you asked me if
I like this uh uh the decision of
capturing on A5 the answer is yes I do
because it poses big questions if you
can't take happily with the Rook you
can't take happily with the pawn what
are you going to do here it just looks
like Yan has to choose lesser of the
evils but David I see the evalar does
not budge is there another option
here I guess uh if he's not scared about
getting checkmated which he should be
yand pomi then he could play a move like
Pawn to B5 guaranteeing that he can take
on A5 there we go it's on the board he
can take on A5 now with the Rook but
this is the problem the white Rook has
found this path over to the king side
it's racing over there Robert as you
kind of as you mentioned it is a it's
not just a fast car it's it's just a
rocket right now those two Rooks heading
over and wow he's breaking his structure
even more Yan he's taking Desperate
Measures to try and cling on I just want
to mention as well the clock situation
for the first time in this match shows
ala ahead he's the one making things
happen what do you make of this Robert
just a shocking decision to take on H5
it looks terrible but looks can be
deceiving you are ruining your own Pawn
structure you're leaving yourself with
an isolated Pawn but perhaps the point
is that black will play King G7 and then
slide into a defensive posture with Rook
to h8 and the H7 Pawn does get DEF
defended in this manner uh I'm looking
at this a-fly Pawn it's going to fall
and when it does fall black is suddenly
going to have some chances at
counterplay on the queen side so King G7
an A Move that deserves an exclamation
point it's the only choice for black to
stay in this game and be able to defend
H7 but Tanya just like in game one are
the tide suddenly turning and in this
game in Yan's favor a bit and now the
time is level as well I it just feels
like it's a roller coaster with these
two it's hard to say who's better
because the moves are so combative that
it just keeps changing the evaluation
but it feels like both of them are
keeping it under control for now with
really difficult to find moves and
Robert I really like this Knight Retreat
you had long time ago pointed out that
F6 square a square that felt like it's
impossible for White's Knight to get to
but with this idea of Knight E2 I can
Envision and now to G3 at some point
this Knight is going to land with a
check on H5 and get to that F6 square
that felt like it was impossible to
reach to you're already pointing out a
Checkmate on the board with those arrows
oh this looks scary and I think that's
why the evaluation went back toward the
center when white took on H5 with the
Rook it should have been the night you
lost an important Tempo I wouldn't have
seen this without uh watching the game
unfold but this Rook takes on H5 was a
little bit Hasty but David despite the
haste despite the assessment being about
level according to the engine the
players don't have that luxury and Yan
doesn't really have that much time to
fend off and attack both on the board
and on the
clock it's just like that last game even
if it does eventually end in a draw it's
not going to be an easy path uh I think
it's deceptive here the evaluation bar
because either white looks like he's
going to deliver Checkmate or White's
queenside will collapse and Black's
queenside pawns will just March down the
board it feels like it's uh nothing in
between right now it's just a pure race
between kind of contrasting ideas here
and yeah I mean it's so tough to defend
when you have no time on the clock Yan
takes this Pawn the most natural move in
the position he's just going to try and
Survive by any means necessary with the
black king and the black pawns will do
the work for him later but now pressure
back on fua he has to back up his idea
by essentially delivering Checkmate the
White Knight is coming but the black
king does have a Escape Route is going
to just run for the Hills run for us run
just over as far away as possible and
um practical terms with two 2 minutes
each on the clock Tanya it's so hard to
call it's a coin toss here it's a game
for all three results and I think draw
is actually the least likely here the
Knight has been planted on F6 The Rook
from B4 can slide over to H4 join the
party on the king side just imagine if
you take on H7 and land a rook there the
G Pawn starts moving forward you're
already targeting the F7 with a pin for
now even though black has an extra Pawn
David I'm picking white I'd want to be
white here what what about you guys
who's pushing for the advantage here
white is pushing for the advantage and
G6 is a huge push even in this position
it would win the game so black needs to
be super careful because a check on the
seventh rank wouldn't just be a check it
would win the bishop behind it the
Knight on F6 is the best piece on the
board that's a stallion it's just
forcing black to deal with all sorts of
checkm threats and look at the composure
from Yap pomi lovely decision to retreat
this bishop I still think G6 is
incredibly dangerous for to deal with
you give away a pawn that seems like a
bad decision but you expose the King on
the seventh Rank and already tactics
revolving around two pieces dropping off
for a rook David what do you make of
this is white really going to press with
G6 or should he slow down a little bit
and find a different improving route I
think he'll be looking at G6 Robert
he'll be looking at just recapturing on
H7 with his Rook as well the top players
they look at forcing moves first the
most direct path if he isn't sure about
the conclusion there if he's not sure
about what comes next then he might take
a time out and start improving pieces
I'm not sure how to improve though
White's light Square Bishop I guess not
participating in the action right now
but it does look like black will soon be
ready to push pawns on the queen side so
I think alera will get itchy fingers
here and do something dramatic do
something very direct uh what that is I
mean more I look at G6 the more I think
it's super tempting but yeah whatever he
decides he needs to do it quickly one
minute feels like a bit of time to
calculate But ultimately one minute will
disappear so quick and he gets the Rooks
off the board but now the black bwn is
only going to be a few squares away is
it just a race now there we go Bertie
the bwn runs but Gary the gwn could also
run in the near future this is getting
really really
dramatic and it's such a tight rope to
walk on because this is the final rapid
game how much risk do you actually take
in this one cuz there's no turning back
from it to me now it looks like the Bon
is more berti is more dangerous than
Gary and I don't think people have said
that too much in the history of Chess
but in this particular
B1 will land with a check Robert yeah I
was just laughing that that was a
hilarious sentence but B this is such a
threat that even after Knight takes
Bishop I still think black can play B3
because Knight takes Knight Pawn to B2
you are not stopping a queen from
landing on B1 with Checkmate so there
may be a way out for white because the
evaluation Mar is in the center but Yan
right now he has the time he should be
calculating can I win with Pawn to B3 I
think that Knight D6 it barely allows
white to escape perhaps there will be a
repetition of moves because the black
king doesn't have enough breathing room
so you can just keep checking it on the
seventh and eighth ranks but this is a
big moment for Yan pami do you take back
this night he says no and the engine
does not budge but there's probably an
only move here after a brilliant Choice
from Yan pomi perhaps the only move from
him to keep the
balance that last move is going to be
like a cold shower for fuia suddenly he
realizes he's got two moves to save
himself or at least two turns before
that black bwn lands and he finds the
best move the only move for white to
save the game and uh I saw a feature
chat saying how can this position be
equal it looks like Black's about to
deliver Checkmate make a new Queen but
Black's King cannot run and uh yeah this
one is now just a draw wow so much drama
20 seconds for fuja he doesn't risk it
he doesn't play on we're about to see a
repetition but what a fight you can see
it on the cameras now it is going to be
a draw both players though just reeling
from that that burst that flurry of
excitement just unbelievable two draws
but such Fighting Chess such a roller
coaster ride so top SE by both these
players and this last one allowing black
spawn to get to B2 and then finding a
repetition both players I think they've
got reasons to be pleased with the chess
that they're playing today they're
putting up quite the show Robert and
we're in for an exciting
Armageddon if the last two games are any
indication yeah the Armageddon is going
to be a brawl a melee between these two
because little has separate them they're
both going on the offensive there has
not been a winning Advantage some small
mistakes here and there but the level of
accuracy between these two I'm amazed
because what ala and Jan both do is they
take their opponent into that deep dark
Forest where you're going to be less
accurate you're going to blunder some
games away neither side will back down
to the other this is such a a great I
want to call it a rivalry between these
two what a fantastic fight we've had in
those in these two games uh just amazing
chess start to finish and the score is
level but the games have been anything
but peaceful and now we're in for an
Armageddon it's going to be about who
gets the black pieces David how
important would it be for the players to
fight for the black pieces in this one
at this point it feels like they might
as well take white it's just been so
chaotic the games it's always come down
to the last few seconds you might as
well have the extra time yes it's been
two draws yes on paper it looks like
having draw odds uh might give an
advantage but I actually think whoever
gets white will be the favorite in this
one I think it's bucking the normal
Trend that we see during matches no
solidity here just Mortal Kombat as you
said punch after punch landed by each uh
this Armageddon is going to be fun to
watch no matter
what when
Al play it's always fun and that's what
it's been today as well to incredible
fights Robert what are you expecting
from this upcoming
armagen they're going to throw
everything at one another maybe those
weapons in the wall will be used as well
I'm not sure but yand pomi he better
bring it because Ali raaza he is going
toe to- Toe with him just like he can
against pretty much any player on the
planet I'm stoked everyone at home
should be stoked as
well cannot wait for the armagen to
start to decide who will play against
Denis lazovic in the losers final to
fight for spot into the Grand Final
we've got a big big armagedon coming up
between these two we'll be back with the
bids don't go
[Music]
anywhere
to
[Music]
mate is in four moves from the position
in front of you don't move until you
figure it out in your
head don't look at me for a
hint I can't do it without moving the
pieces yes you
can clear the lines of men in your head
one at a time time and the King will be
left standing alone like a guy in a
street
corner I'll make it easier for
[Music]
you what was that about I thought it
would help how does F help you know
visualization and stuff I'm not picking
up the
pieces sometimes you don't need to do
anything crazy to get better you just
need to reassess your chess I'm
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley and I'm
presenting Jeremy silman's how to
reassess your chess now on chessable so
go to chess.com
yourest and start reassessing your chest
today
[Music]
[Applause]
Bo
[Music]
ahahahahahahahahah
oh
[Music]
welcome to the most exciting format in
chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker our
mageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with Lois bid gets to choose their color
usually black in those coveted draw ODS
let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence and just a few moments from now
we will have the players getting ready
to play there Armageddon and the bids
are in it is Ali RZA fuja who wins the
bid with 6 minutes and 55 seconds he
starts with the black pieces Yan napam
Nishi will start with the base time of
10 minutes and gets the white pieces
which means he has to win must win for
Yan no more draws in a match where we've
had two draws so far it's going to be
about flagging it's going to be about
the speed it's going to be about who
gets their opponent to start thinking
first David are we expecting more
opening surprises in this one well that
seems to be the recurring pattern two
games so far in this match two opening
surprises and uh it's been fua both
times on the back foot early so Yan
needs to hope it's uh Third Time Lucky
that he can launch another surprise and
catch fua off guard especially with the
Armageddon clock situation uh there we
see him on the camera fuja yeah he's
just trying to get in the zone he knows
he will need to be quicker at least in
the early phases Robert he will indeed
and I'm actually a bit surprised by the
bids that we saw I'm not sure if Ali
Raza has been watching and noting what
yand pom's bid in previous days but I
think Jan's bids have tended to be
higher he likes the white pieces in
Armageddon so for fuia to start with
under seven minutes on the clock that's
quite a low bid I think he could have
successfully bit higher not just because
that's what it would have been in this
case but just based on Yan's bidding
history maybe he just has incredible
faith and belief in his Mouse skills
alira fuja and you can't really blame
him for that he is the bullet Beast he
is a spee chest specialist off we go it
starts with one4 it's another Berlin are
we going to see another B4 sacrifice not
this time David not this time again it's
the Berlin but it's the anti- Berlin
with uh no peace trades no uh kind of
early clarification of the Center White
also keeping his Spanish Bishop alive so
still one of the main positions and a
bit of a think there from fuia before
deciding to try and blow open the center
trying to seek early clarification here
fixing the pawn structure at least and
uh Robert I feel the moves are going to
be much quicker here much more natural
at least for fora compared to the
earlier games we saw apparently we just
saw oh Bishop takes F2 check again again
Bishop takes F2 check with que5 to
follow and both players are either
trusting the other or completely missing
this I think we need to bring up an
analysis board so everyone can
understand what was missed two turns in
a row that at this point Rook E1 allows
Bishop takes F2 check the king takes
back otherwise you lose the rook and
queen C5 hits the king and the bishop
the only way to block a check and
protect the bishop would be Knight to D4
but then black can take it in numerous
ways including with the Knight because
you can't even take back without losing
your queen so this was a tremendous
opportunity for all a FIA it would have
been pretty much game his winning upon
Pawn opening up the white king but both
Players missed it two turns in a row and
instead we're back to a pretty normal
looking position so Tanya I think we can
breathe once more the players they don't
even know that they missed it we're back
in more standard territory I I'm Gob
smacked Robert I cannot believe what
just happened but it's insane how much
of this we see where at the top level
they just don't expect a blunder early
on they just seem to trust their
opponent sometimes too much much and
that Bishop takes spawn a huge missed
opportunity unbelievable stuff I mean it
was it would have just been close to an
ala win right out of the opening with
extremely high stakes there David he
could have won in 10 15 moves as black
that's a real Rarity it knocked down
their accuracy we see below the boards
there both were down in the mid-70s
that's how dramatic it was um but that's
what we call Mutual blindness you trust
the opponent uh you nearly never a 2800
player blunder in one move especially
with white early in the opening and
ultimately they're kind of using
patterns that they're familiar with but
it was in the pishy to mix up his move
order and Alara who didn't have the
alertness to punish I think it's just
that Armageddon they're both so in the
mindset of getting the moves down on the
board as quickly as possible that they
didn't pause to think uh so
understandable um it's very difficult
when you're in the Heat of the Moment
easy for us without the pressure of the
clocks but all if he loses now if he
goes back and checks this game he will
beat kicking himself so uh yeah it's
good for NE good for both players that
neither of them kind of spotted it and
have realized otherwise we would have
seen a far bigger reaction Robert
ultimately it looks like a very balanced
middle game instead I think that ala can
still be happy with the position he's
obtained because he has the healthier
Pawn structure no double pawns on the
file and for black all your pieces are
active protecting one another and with
this latest move you're forcing back
White's most active piece this Knight
that was out on C4 so I really am
enjoying the way that alza is playing
this game the Knight did step back to E3
here but black has claimed a lot of
space a healthier Pawn structure and wow
that is a huge decision Tanya to isolate
your pawns on the queen side I think
he's just going for activity I'm loving
what Ali rzza is doing he might have
missed Bishop takes Pawn earlier on with
a huge Advantage but this also looks
like a really happy outcome out of a
Berlin that Knight is not stopping at E5
it's going to jump into D3 it's going at
the right time it's going to find a post
on D3 once we see some trades on the D
file and then will white be forced to
capture that Knight once it lands on D3
give a really strong passer with the ewn
capturing back on that square it's going
to be big questions for Yan to answer
I'm still thinking about that big miss
that happened and I think it's really
good news that both of them did not
realize that they didn't see what they
missed it's better that they check it
after the game uh because then it can
really really throw you off still liking
Black's position I I think the trades do
favor Black whatever white plays Black
can take on D1 now double up with that
Rook on d8 and throw that Knight onto D3
eventually we're seeing all of that
unfold now Tanya that is a monster
Square the Black Knight is going to
evolve like a Pokemon into a a more
magnificent Beast right now it's going
to become a real octopus with tentacles
all over the board that black knight it
cannot be tolerated on D3 I agree it
will be whipped off exchanged once it
gets there but yeah with the draw up his
sleeve fua he's also eaten into the time
Advantage now under two minutes the
difference between them I think he's
becoming more and more of a favorite
every single move he's done nothing
wrong at all Robert um he's kind of
ruined his own Pawn structure on
occasion throughout the three games but
so energetic for R's play energetic is a
great word to describe it and after
Knight D3 if white does take this night
in comes a pass Pawn for black with a
rook behind it so this just looks deeply
unpleasant for Yan his Rook it looks
good on the a file but it can't get
involved on the first rank because this
bishop on C1 isn't getting out and Jan
he's in for a big think here there's no
way you like your position Knight D3
also has threats of Knight takes F2
there will be tactics on that square
once again so for both of these players
who don't know that there was a huge
blunder out of the opening it's all Ali
Raa Fu at this point Tanya I just don't
even see how white does anything to
coordinate and I think the big problem
is what you pointed out that Bishop on
C1 if it was on the H2 B8 diagonal if it
was developed already it would be a
position that's totally playable for
white but right now with this bishop
stuck behind his own Knight not having
the activity Black's Knight has landed
with a punch on D3 cannot be allowed to
stay alive at that point and aliad
pauses I would be so tempted to just
pick it up with that E4 Pawn create a
pass a b wow he takes a different
decision David he goes with Rook takes
Bishop does that surprise you it really
does surprise me um it's an energetic
move he's trying to play with pieces
rather than pawns but just uh kind of
setting up this protected pass porn
forever pretty much that would have tied
down all of White's forces um I
understand the question mark attached to
that move I think it was not the most
natural option and uh yeah I think
actually the kind of instinctive move
was the better one here however look at
this black now has a strong move black
can just line up on the defile conquer
the defile and again the the problem
piece the problem child of White's
position is that Bishop that's such a
sad block of wood on C1 so yeah still
black in the driver seat but I agree
Tanya I think it could have been even
more clinical there even more emphatic
his Advantage if he had taken with the
pawn and uh npom she still suffering
here with white now que to D7 R David if
you ever called me a block of wood I
think I would just cry that felt super
insulting but in the nicest way possible
it's like when the best person you know
tries to hurt someone else's feelings
just that kind of pleasant trash talk
but it's true this bishop on C1 is a
miserable miserable piece it means that
the Rook on A1 can't help out in the
defense if this knight ever moves from
E3 there will be a check on the first
rank that looks really scary and look at
what Ali Rea is doing he is trading off
White's best piece and that also is a
defender of this F5 pawn and this
critical D1 Square which could lead to a
Checkmate on the first rank I think that
question mark that was given to Ala for
taking with the Rook if this were not a
he moves on with a draw game I would
agree with it because Pawn takes D3 it
was more of an aggressive plan that had
a clear path forward for black but he's
just trying to stabilize he doesn't need
to win a draw is a win so from that
perspective Tanya I think we could
forgive him as his position remains
marvelous especially with the way it's
proceeded after that this move Knight D5
lining up the queen and the Rook they
are checkmating idea that will once the
bishop might even fall back to C7 you
can line up the queen and the bishop on
that diagonal try and Target the H2
Square you could think about a rook D1
back rank ideas coming with this Knight
trade being offered with the F5 Pawn
about to fall it just looks like it's
big big problems here for uh Yan to to
handle and to solve and the time
Advantage the advantage on the clock has
completely disappeared
David it has evaporated suddenly Fu's
moves are easier uh I mean right now oh
this is a trick I guess I was going to
say black can just take the white F Pawn
but uh Black's moves are instinctive
quick he's attacking remember that last
game we talked about attacking moves
being quicker than finding these really
difficult defenses but um yeah it's very
much all about Black and only really the
clock and his nerves can trip him up
here um Yan is trying to complicate the
issue but look at it on the camera
shaking his head in aomi he's relied on
this trick Bishop takes H6 that was
Untouchable because there would have
been a night Fork winning the black
queen but yet again the black queen
steps back Robert you mentioned it
stabilizing just so calm his moves he
knows in the back of his mind it is
Armageddon you can see the experience
from fuja here and he's just bullying
the pishi at this point the black F Pawn
is going to be a battering ram in the
near future still looks phenomenal for
black still doing everything right and
if White's best options are to trade off
pieces and get into a worse position
there that still doesn't help Yan knows
he needs to win so even if the engine
goes in completely in Black's favor Yan
has to go for lines that scare ala and
with the clock evening up why should is
a be scared he doesn't have a weak King
in fact he's the one with the attack
this bishop as T mentioned can slide
back to C7 at any moment including right
now Bishop on G5 you can even boot that
one away with Pawn to F6 I'm not sure
it's necessary I'm not seeing plans for
white and that's the biggest hurdle for
Yan naishi it's not even the evaluation
bar he just doesn't have a
plan I think the one thing that perhaps
uh Yan is relying on well right now he's
got to move the bishop but maybe lining
up the rook and the queen trying to targ
with the E4 pawn and now that idea has
gone out of the window at least for now
a trade being offered which is captured
by the Knight he takes it back and now I
feel like the positions eased out a wow
ala he's playing the mat situation the
Armageddon situation and not the board
that's what's clear to me David yeah
certainly he would not have traded off
all of those pieces so quickly so
confidently if he wasn't sure that he
would secure a draw here as black and
after all I think he's uh well within
his rights to play like this Black's
Rook is supremely strong the black queen
nicely centralized as long as you take
care of the black king I think you can
safely just about take a Pawn on B4 here
not worry about the Rook infiltrating
the white Rook there um yeah I think
he's got the draw up his sleeve he
should be able to hold but playing for a
draw is a bit of a negative mindset so
he needs to be careful that he doesn't
affect too many more of his decisions in
the meantime Robert though he's still
doing everything right he's tied down
the white pieces Black's Queen Black's
Rook better than their counterparts
and look at this last move Queen to G3
not even allowing the white king to step
closer if King H1 is your move it's
because he can't do anything else so
watch out the one thing I wouldn't want
if I am ala is to see a queen land on H5
because if I can imagine a rook also
landing on a square like A8 these arrows
they don't make sense because it's not
going to happen but if these pieces can
line up in this manner that would be a
Checkmate so Rook A1 next is Neo's idea
and he didn't want Queen takes E3 to be
check for forcing the Queens off the
board so actually quite a good last move
King to H1 and if I'm ala I don't want
to burn too much clock I I want to find
the accurate reply but now hitting about
two minutes oh a G6 play that means
there are going to be checks on both of
these last two ranks Tanya I don't know
if I'm as confident as I was before in
all's chances to hold this and move on
some really practical decisions were
taken by Ali Rea maybe not objectively
the best ones in a better position
trading off pieces getting a queen Rook
versus queen Rook but now it's still
game on he's got about a minute deficit
to Yan's time there's no increment he's
touching he's under two minutes right
now the black king potentially could be
on say watch out F6 was threatened
forcing fuja to make his Queen a bit
inactive I think aliar wanted to trade
off with Rook D1 get as many pieces off
the board as possible Yan very smartly
there stops any further trade but it
does come at the cost of a pawn but
David there's a trap there is a trap if
Black's Rook takes the pawn on E3
suddenly it walks into a double attack
it's an undefended Square Queen A7 check
would win that Rook so fuja shaking his
head there the nerves are kicking in now
he's down to the one and a half minute
Mark and the words of Magnus Carson are
ringing in my mind he has gone on record
as saying Yan is one of the best players
in the world when it's just heavy pieces
when it's just the major pieces Rooks
and queens because he's so alert to
these traps these double attacks as we
saw there Pawn to G5 is not a happy move
creating some more lift some more air
for the black king but also weakening
some squares and Yan he's going to up
the pace now he has to hustle on the
clock and fua is far far from safe look
at this more threats Robert every move
from Yan just creating a threat but Rook
D1 always he trading Queens this is a
God send for black trading off these
pieces is not just helpful I think wins
a pawn by force if you take on D1 the
black queen can slide right back to D6
with check against the white king that
steps forward and down goes this B4 Pawn
and with all the trades happening it
means we're getting closer to a draw
from an objective standpoint but I have
one eye on the clock one minute 6
seconds for a bullet Beast like fuja
that's an eternity but Jan he's not too
shabby himself in scrambles he will try
to win on
time I think at some point we've got to
have both our eyes on the clock because
he's touching a minute Mark and how many
moves do you think with 60 seconds he's
picked up he's grabbed that pawn uh Yan
is going to try to flag Ali Resa there
no doubts about that with a minute on
the clock how many moves can you
actually make with the mouse
David uh if you're the top guys and you
know how to pre moove you can make a 100
moves with a minute on the clock but uh
with the nerves as an added ingredient
of I'm not so sure but look what he's
doing Robert he's protected everything
now he can just move with the King The
Black Queen doesn't even need to do too
much anymore just plant her on D5 surely
this is safe now for fia the queen
protects everything which means that the
only quote unquote idea that white will
have is to give checks and he goes H4 he
wants to give a sneaky check with a mate
idea but now that this Pawn is captured
and the queen centralizes all right it's
actually objectively winning at this
stage for black but a draw is equ to win
so as long as Aliva he keeps the pace
that he has this is not a blunder I'm
actually removing that right now I can
do that you know this is a it's a good
move because if you could force the draw
you win the
match Yan he's just checking he's just
hoping now but 3637 seconds Al Raz is
forcing the Queens off otherwise it's
Checkmate is this the anavan tournament
he's giving up and our Queen F5 trades
the queens and this is all over the C
Pawn will push it will be faster and Yan
on the camera and on the board gives up
it is the end of the road for yan yan is
eliminated Ali Riza fuja makes it
through to fight against Dennis laic in
the losers final and what a match this
uh has been Robert it was a great match
three draws were the results but the
games they had so much life to them
there are so many people who think oh a
draw that means that it wasn't an
exciting match this was a huge clash
between two of the hungriest players on
the planet only one could make it
through it's Ali Raza fua who Magnus
Carlson said he saw as the favorite he
moves on and that means he plays a
teenager next credit to Magnus for that
uh that bit of Prophecy there he said
it's going to be a really close fight
and it's one that's going to be really
hard to pick but he did pick ol has a
slight slight favorite and it went down
to the wire it went down to a big
Armageddon and eventually alza fuja
prevailed in this one uh David what an
Armageddon this was what a fight it was
what were the highlights for
you the highlights it was just Fu's
energetic play he was never backing down
yes he took kind of pragmatic decisions
towards the end but um yeah he always
had it under control it feels like these
last uh 12 months 24 months it's been a
real Changing of the Guard I'm sad that
a player of my generation nand pomi is
out of the tournament uh now it's the
turn of the youngsters but of course
that big boss still lurking in the
distance on Wednesday Magnus Carson uh
but yeah credit to fuja we're gonna see
him go again and uh we're gonna see him
take on a fellow youngster this time
Dennis
lazic it is the big losers final which
is coming up between Dennis lazovic and
and Ali rzza fuja it was such a close
match right with those two draws and
then fighting it turned out to be really
critical for Ali Raza to get black in
this game because there were those
moments where he could make practical
decisions even though they weren't
objectively the best ones Robert well I
think it's objectively the best decision
even though that annoying engine says
you're wrong he was right because he was
never in any danger he held the draw
without any problems of course Yan had
to give everything away to try to win
but I think ala played a more or less
perfect game in an Armageddon
situation it really was and it came down
to a big battle in the rapid in the
Armageddon David if you had to highlight
one moment from this match which one
would it
be so many highlights uh I'm just going
to talk purely about the Armageddon
though and uh I just wanted to talk
about the moment where for fuja he
pretty much banked it and here we see
the game review in the op browser I just
wanted to highlight Knight to D3 we
talked about this piece just being a
beast look at the tentacles here out
just uh kind of hitting everything the
F2 Square the bishop on C1 it had to be
eliminated and uh yes Rook takes D3 a
controversial decision but fuja over the
next few turns Consolidated a tip for
everyone at home avoid tactics if you
know you're already in control
especially if you're happy with a
peaceful result and Knight to G4 it
would be easy for someone to panic here
easy to go wrong especially against uh
mighty opponent like yanomi Knight to E5
is a big threat but um okay there we go
the board has just changed up but yeah
essentially he traded off pieces over
the next few moves the Bishops
disappeared the knights disappeared and
heed it towards safety so this was a
previous Checkmate from fuja he's just
been the man uh he's been so on form
this tournament so far and this was one
of the most beautiful checkmates that we
saw in the Champions Chester sacrificing
that bishop and to moting to H1 so many
great games by all these players but for
yanomi the road does come to an end
undoubtedly we will see him back in the
Champions chest off for Ali Raza the
fight does continue and he did show his
medal in that armagedon he missed that
big opportunity out of the opening
Robert but never let it go out of his
control it's because the players they
don't have that engine off to the side
alerting them hey you missed something
here find it next time so ala he is
going to be annoyed as he reviews the
game we see all these players
immediately they start analyzing after
the game concludes but with that Miss as
an exception that was a blunder two
moves in a row uncharacteristic of both
players it really was a wonderful
performance from alaan hats off to Yan
pongi because it takes two players to
Showcase their talents and their
fighting spirit so we had a really
fantastic match and for ala his day is
not done and our day is not done as
we've got a big matchup coming up for
that spot to the Grand final of the
chessable Masters we will be back as the
youngsters take on each other Ali Resa
fuja fighting against the 17-year-old
Dennis lavic get your coffee get your
tea get whatever you want and come right
back we'll be back in just a
[Music]
few
n
I grew up in the small Forest Town of
vauda I've lived here all my
life when I was five my father taught me
the game and soon therea took me to the
local chess
club I can't really remember my life
without chess I feel like it's always
been
there I met my wife through chess my
profession is
chess
I don't play chess to win I'm not that
competitive uh I love how the pieces
move I love the
game I love how everything around me
becomes
still when I'm behind the chess board
time doesn't flow the same way until the
clock runs
out in the spring of 2021 time seem to
have run out I was diagnosed with
hoskinson's disease which is a form of
cancer I was 35 and suddenly my life
changed it was a strange time and chess
didn't seem to matter at
all but I was optimistic I uh trusted
the treatment plan and the doctors that
were helping me and I felt it was in
there hands now the chemotherapy
radiation uh at the worst I could barely
walk around
walk that it really puts things in
perspective like like uh if I have a bad
position now yeah I mean it's really
it's it's no big deal you know so maybe
in that sense it helps that that you
have a more of
um uh different kind of attitude to to
to to
life
there are definitely also positive
things I take from that time when I was
not uh
well um I think it gives you kind of
different perspective on life on on on
everything actually so it's uh that's
definitely not only um
negative it takes a long time to recover
but just players or anything if not
patients it was crazy because one month
before the tourament in V I still had my
varation therapy finished so it was it
was way too early actually to to stop
playing but I I wanted to desperately be
at that tournament I barely prepared for
the games because I I was just too tired
I just I only played the games I had
dinner went back to my room slept most
of the time I had put that tournament as
an um as a goal
best T I ever
played then at the end of the year after
um 16 fi attempts I became D champion
and that was really the cherry on on the
cake that was huge for me I was ecstatic
it was the feeling of I'm
[Music]
back all those failures all those
setbacks they um never seem to matter
now what is important is that I've Lov
chess ahead of
me I always wait for the moment when uh
I wake up and I realize that I today I
don't really feel like looking at CH but
it just never
[Music]
happens my name is and L me and I'm a
Dutch Grand
Master
n
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please oh
he's losing now he walk right into the
and they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar's going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one more check me two seconds oh my
God why we get
in the players are getting ready we are
definitely ready and we hope that you're
ready as well because it's high stakes
matches in the next one as alira fuja
fights against the 17-year-old Dennis
lazic who's been creating waves this
entire chessel master
and David I'm going to throw my first
question to you put yourself in Dennis's
shoes right now you've just watched the
action that unfolded between ala and
yanomi what are you taking away from it
and what's your strategy going into this
one I wish I were Dennis lazic but if I
were him if I were still in the Chess
Masters at this late stage um I would
actually be taking the positives Yan and
fuja they were punching each other they
were knocking each other down they were
tiring each other out so Dennis being
able to relax and sit back knowing he
would face the winner he should be
reving in the fact that uh something at
least some energy would have been
drained from them of course it's not
going to be easy if fua can maintain
that level Dennis will still start as an
underdog but uh he's done so well so far
and if he can maintain that momentum he
had yesterday against Magnus Carlson
taking one win one game Victory then uh
he should go into this game this uh this
next match with much on the line so much
much on the line not just his energy
against Magnus but Dennis lavic has
taken down Anish Kiri Hikaru Nakamura
Jose Martinez yes he lost to Magnus
Carlson but not before throwing in one
of his own punches in there Robert
getting that big historical win
yesterday putting up a massive fight
what are you expecting when he takes on
alira well you were asking you know if
we're ready if the audience is ready
Dennis laar was born ready he is an
absolute fighter he does not lose very
often that is probably his biggest
calling card he's not trying to play
tactical Affairs he just plays solid
fundamental chess he's maybe the Tim
Duncan of chess if you will hasn't hit
the highest Heights yet but he's just 17
years old it's his third division one
appearance Tanya his rating over the
board not nearly as high as it is online
and he's also proven himself at so many
speed chess events so Oliver AA he may
be the higher rated player he may have
more accolades but he is taking Dennis
lavik very seriously you said Dennis
doesn't lose that often let let me just
back that up by telling everyone that
from the very start of the chessable
Masters counting the Swiss planes
counting the placements and the ride
through division one Dennis lavic only
has lost to David Anton and Magnus
Carlson that's just two players who
managed to get the dub in against this
17-year-old Phenom he takes in Ali Resa
for R Ali Reza who has been in the
elimination bracket since day one since
his lost to pedv has also been really
impressive but look at that Robert some
impressive performances by Dennis over
the board Dennis lazic he is underrated
and he's certainly dangerous look at
these performances all of them so much
better on paper than his rating it's
because he is underrated but somebody
who does not rate him lowly someone who
takes him seriously is Ali Raza f
because ala he was The Shining Star he
had a meteor rise he knows that some of
these other players can do what he did
in the past so Alara he just beat y Palm
now is not the time to stop giving it
your all now's not the time to sit and
get complacent he's got a spot in the
grand finals on the line and he's taking
on Dennis lavic who is no easy customer
and we're
off we're off it's e45 we've seen that
consistently throughout today and uh
okay it's the Italian opening so no more
berlins bring the S relief everyone
instead the Italian the slow Yoko piano
promises a lot of maneuvering allara
here he's going for a long game it feels
like where he's hoping to catch Dennis a
bit later on and um this one t so many
different move orders so many different
setups for both sides uh are you
surprised by this Choice from
ANA it's really one of those openings
which seem to say that alira is
channeling his inner
you know anti- young player chess you're
out of any theoretical knowledge we've
been singing praises about Dennis's
opening his theoretic theoretical ideas
so getting this kind of a structure
where one move here and there you could
put in an A4 you could take out your
knight you could go shot Castle you
could delay your castling at any moment
we could see the a pawn falling falling
ahead the bishop falling backwards to B3
so all these ideas give rise to these
structures and these plans rather than a
concrete line so I think it's good
approach against Dennis lazic Robert I
was smiling because everything you were
saying you said the light score Bishop
could Retreat and immediately did Black
castles first and for alizza he has not
castled his own King some players start
with the nigh hop and in fact there it
is because he pushed his Pawn up to H3
he took away Black's access to this very
critical square and that means he can
delay his short Castle he may not Castle
short if he can launch a huge attack so
for Dennis David the big question can
you should you play this move
D5 think if you can get away with it you
should and now might be the opportune
moment um I'm just I'm sitting here
smiling I've got to say because ala fua
he's employing the treatment of the
Italian game that I used to play
throughout my childhood I think up until
I was a Grandmaster 18 19 years old uh I
was just playing just this and nothing
else and uh it's nice to see him dig
deep into the uh kind of uh at least
allow me to go down and trip on memory
lane and uh I used to get a lot of
criticism for playing like this from the
Grand Old Men of British chess they were
saying you know this is just lazy you're
not even learning anything you're just
moving pieces around but there's so much
poison as you highlighted there Robert
and uh I'm hoping Dennis doesn't play
moves like Pawn H6 because that would be
like a red rag to a bull white gon would
throw itself forward and we'd see a
blitz attack on the black king yeah to
answer your question D5 is probably a
good move from my experience at least
it's what black should be doing Bishop
to E6 would be another uh potential uh
kind of way of meeting this setup just
to trade-off pieces making White's
potential attack a little less dangerous
but Dennis certainly Tanya the one to
start burning time on the clock early
caught by
surprise early on and that's also one of
the advantages of taking this setup that
we've been discussing because there is
no concrete Theory you know you've got
these plans these ideas but the move
orders keep switching up and with a 10
minute 2C increment time control it can
become quite tricky to deal with it all
these moves that you're discussing
Bishop to E6 D5 I agree with you David
H6 is asking for trouble creating a hook
on the king side really inviting the
pawn RAM on the G file it looks
extremely dangerous we've been talking
about Dennis's style right he prefers to
keep things under control he likes that
solid approach do you think that's
perhaps why he doesn't choose the move
D5 and goes for the more developing
solid Bishop E6
Robert definitely and he acknowledges
that he will receive double pawns if
white takes but an open file anytime you
have double pawns you gain some access
for your Rook so it was a big moment D5
would have taken us into a more tactical
Waters this Pawn chain makes sure the E5
Pawn is safe whenever pla black pushes
D5 you're creating Pawn tension that's
good to activate some of your pieces but
you may have a vulnerable Pawn on E5
later and wow I like this Retreat from
aldera and the reason I like it is
because I don't know what he's aiming
for he doesn't want to trade pieces
keeping more of them on the board means
that there are more options but David
you like to say this in Rapid chess you
often don't want to have too many
options because then you burn the clock
and you may spend too much time trying
to figure out a way
forward yeah that's right often you just
want easy natural forced moves for
better or worse at least you get them
down on the board it helps you to play a
bit quicker but here the players both
have a bunch of time left and finally
Dennis does break with D5 um I think
he's chosen a good moment for it we were
talking about playing this Pawn break
one move earlier but now at least he's
forced the white light squar Bishop a
bit more passive and ala pretty much is
at a fork in the road right now he
either takes that pawn on D5 from my
experience that kind of it can backfire
black has a bit more space in the center
but the black E5 Pawn can be a bit of a
Target or you continue being provocative
by playing a move like Queen to E2 you
essentially say yes you can take on e4
but the Queen stay on the board and
slowly I'm going to kind of Slither
around and uh try to attack your king
the black king moves like Bishop to G5
in the air after that Knight to G5 in
the air okay he goes for the former
option of trading pawns maybe slightly
less ambitious but also a lot safer and
uh now I'm expecting Dennis to recapture
I'm not sure with which piece actually I
was going to say originally the Knight
but also taking with the queen would be
perfectly viable and objectively at
least black is doing fine black has a
Target we talk about backward pawns the
D3 Pawn Tanya reminiscent of an earlier
uh an earlier game with a a weak for the
white side yeah and that just invites
doubling up on the dline long-term
weakness there I am surprised with this
trade on D5 and it tennis chooses a
third option not with the Knight with
the queen but brings on his Bishop which
also a really nice idea you place it on
a good Square you're provoking white to
go C4 to try to push that Bishop out but
that creates so many Central weaknesses
uh like D4 the square that you're
highlighting and as long as the bishop
is on D5 you always have to watch out
for a trade on F3 or a potential E4 at
the right time black can always step up
with the queen to D7 double up on the D
file start put putting pressure on the D
line to me Robert it looks like Dennis
should be very pleased with the opening
outcome but as someone who has played
this position from the black side many
times including an over theboard
classical chess I've lost some pretty
hurtful games I'm going to say it looks
like everything's under control you
start feeling confident yeah I'm I'm
equalizing this is great but white has
this very natural plan of bringing a
knight to F5 and there are all sorts of
sacrifices in the air on G7 as a bishop
coming out to G5 so you can't just think
that yeah the engine probably approves
my play that's it what is Black's actual
plan that is the hard part of positions
like this white on the other hand has
simple moves Queen E2 and Knight Bishop
G5 Knight F5 sometimes black even brings
the bishop to C5 and back to f8 just to
preemptively say I understand you want
to go after my king let's get into a
ball let's be safe here but that does
take time it allows white to poke at the
center as David mentioned a rook coming
to E1 later so I actually feel like
these positions are quite challenging
for black to play so David I'm not
surprised at least that Dennis Laz
continues to spend time getting himself
down to nearly five minutes while Al has
more than
eight might be concerning for the fans
of Dennis lazic this kind of time usage
then again he did this against Magnus
Carlson on multiple occasions and we
learned that Dennis is a bit of a demon
uh in the kind of bullet segment of each
game just uh super resourceful and wow
his last
move no I'm in two minds about it yes
he's clarifying the central tension he's
being really direct here trying to force
a draw almost by going for symmetry with
the pawns but it is a bit of a negative
decision and temporarily Black's
position looks a bit loose fua instantly
develops his bishop and yes Knights
might disappear from the board yes
pieces might be exchanged but suddenly
the white Bishops look really menacing
the C7 Pawn is a big Target tactically
in the near future the H7 Pawn a big
Target um Robert does this feel like uh
he's just playing a bit too safe he's
trying to force the issue when he didn't
need to panic this early I think at
first glance it does appear that way
particularly that C7 Pawn is loose in
the event of a queen trade I think
Dennis should continue trading here I
would play Bishop C4 I would be
concerned that white is about to play
Queen D3 Rook to D1 one of the Rooks I'm
not sure which and take control of some
of the Central files he actually allows
Queen D3 because he was so worried about
this loose Pawn on C7 that he brings his
Bishop to its defense but I yeah I'm
starting to like oi raz's position that
Bishop on G3 it's attacking and
defending the bishop on C2 and it goes
after the black king for some reason I
like White's position but then I'm
thinking about t black has done nothing
wrong and no longer seems to have some
huge
weaknesses huge weaknesses I don't see a
single weakness on the board for black
currently I agree with your point that
the bishop on G3 was eyeing the C7 Pawn
which is why I really like this quick
move that Dennis played he improves that
Bishop position to B6 uh making sure
that pawn stays defended whenever
there's a potential Queen trade so he's
kind of looking ahead preempting that
Queen trade at some point so the pawns
are defended I like that Bishop on D5 uh
yes I agree that it feels that White's
pieces might be more active right now
that bishop and cidu may line up with
the queen attacking 87 but it doesn't
feel like there are any threats that are
going to be too difficult for black to
actually handle in the position as long
as this bishop stays on D5 I'm expecting
the Queens to be traded off I think
black's still doing fine here
David I think I was just uh kind of
reeling from the shock of Pawn to E4 it
felt like Dennis didn't even want to try
to uh be better with the black but
ultimately a draw would be a decent
result for him and um you're right if
ala can't find anything in the next two
or three then this position could well
just fizzle out um so that's why the top
players they are so kind of sensitive to
the key moments in games when Trends
might be about to turn all Roa invests
his time here and now and uh yeah if he
can't whip up an attack I think Roberts
Queen to D3 will be met by Bishop E4 um
then yeah maybe it's just level maybe
Dennis has got this all under control I
tend to trust him he's Mr Invincible
he's so hard to beat he always seems to
have a defensive answer at least but
alera this is a key moment Rook to E1
offering some trades I like this move
he's controlling some squares now Queen
to D3 a much bigger threat and wow
Robert asking trying to provoke black
into taking on F3 right now I think that
would be a mistake from Dennis's
perspective in terms of giving white the
bishop pair on an open board but I'm not
really sure he has a huge choice because
Rook D1 that could win a piece on the
next turn as the bishop gets pinned and
there are ways to pile up pressure on
the PIN Bishop so for Dennis that would
mean moving the queen out of the file
and Rook D1 still will be available to
White in the near future or taking this
accepting that white will have control
of some key squares particularly the
light squares but the pawn structure is
shattered so he doesn't take I think
that Dennis's style is to keep the
status quo he wants Symmetry and for ala
once again he needs to prove that he can
have more than just an attractive
looking position he needs to get
something a little more and Tanya I
don't immediately see it all of the key
squares in the position black has under
control I agree with you Queen F6 I
really like it he delays taking on F3
right now white doesn't have the option
to immediately go with Rook to D1
because there's a threat two pieces
attacking F3 only one pie one Pawn is
defending on F3 so white still needs to
spend a move uh are you going to retreat
with the Knight that doesn't look very
pleasant either I don't really see a
good Square for the Knight you can go
Queen E2 and then black will have the
decision to either line up be the first
to bring his Rook to d8 but you have to
watch out a move like Rook d8 could
actually maybe run into Bishop H4 there
are tactics everywhere Bishop takes F3
and it's going to be a complete mess I'm
not sure who that works out for but I
like this approach keep your Bishop back
keep that Bishop on D5 alive and Robert
you mentioned Styles here David I want
to ask you this question that for these
two players fighting this big big match
against each other is it fair to say
this is an absolute Clash of styles
definitely and uh I didn't expect this
type of position purely because of that
style aspect Tanya I thought Alla would
play something really really Dynamic
really testing forcing Dennis to kind of
walk a tight rope but this is a bit more
strategic Alara more a fiery player uh
Dennis lazic of course rock solid as
we've uh as we've mentioned so Dennis it
feels like he's kind of asserting his
type of position on Alara right now
Alara however Queen to E2 still asking
some questions now there's a big threat
Queen to D3 double attack
and finally forces the first imbalance I
think you called it Tanya it's this
Clash of styles it's kind of just
testing the waters here and it is a
short match so it will be about who's
able to navigate this coming position
better ala keeps the Queens on Robert
and uh Bishop pair but fractured
structure how big do you think White's
Advantage is if any at
all I like this bishop on C2 it's in red
because it can be dangerous but of
course these pawns are in red because
they're bad double and icely just hard
to team up on on and I just want to note
their accuracy these players are playing
very precise chess and for ala yeah he's
known for his aggression his tactical
style but when it the position it
liquidates simplifies he can play great
end games and what Ali Razer does and
Fabiano Carana has spoken about this on
his podcast the ccor podcast and many
others have too is that oi razer's play
is less accurate I'm going to put that
in air quotes but it's because he brings
his opponent's accuracy down too and
this is why we are all saying that
Dennis lavic is getting a position in
his style both of the players super
accurate to this point no mistakes
whatsoever no brilliancies no blunders
nothing that is an empty scorecard
beneath the board it's because every
move it keeps the position exactly where
it was slightly ever so slightly better
for black initially and now for white
Tanya I mean no budging between these
two do you believe that one side can
gain the upper hand as we see the time
now both players under four minutes just
slightly slightly for white and it comes
down to this bishop pair and long term
yes the double pwns do compensate black
for that Bishop pair for not having that
extra Bishop but look at that last move
always eyeing that Knight on C6 you're
threatening to pick up a pawn if black
isn't careful there could be ideas of
taking on C6 the A6 Pawn might fall if
your queen is uh moves away from F6 the
next move that we might be even seeing
is the queen stepping up to the center
of the board Queen to E4 comes to mind
setting up tricks not only against the
C6 Knight but ideas like Bishop H4 in
the air to me it just feels like black
will have to watch out for these Bishops
creating a bit of Havoc around the black
king now that it's placed on a dark
Square lining up skewers on the board
meanwhile it's not so easy David for
black to continue finding ways to maybe
trade pieces I don't see how you can do
that to try to create attack to try to
create a direct threat I don't see how
to do that what do you think do you
think that black can still find a way to
trade some pieces because that will
really help the cause yeah he would love
that right now Dennis lazovic if he
could somehow neutralize White's Bishop
pair trade off the Queens but yeah it's
just so difficult to find moves and Rook
to D7 given a question mark I actually
think it's a a fine move he's got a
clear idea at least Rook to E7 would be
next if given the opportunity to uh try
and trade off Rooks Queens I noticed
there are actually some tactics in the
air there so you have to be slightly
careful but um Dennis yeah I don't envy
his clock situation on the camera he
looks a bit stressed down to two minutes
as well and I don't envy how kind of
nonobvious his moves are so all of these
small things plus my inherent bias for
the bishop pair do make me think that
ala this is his chance to strike but uh
still of course hard work to be done yet
to kind of make inroads into the black
position for now is just about solid
enough and solid is Dennis lazovic
calling card so uh Robert question mark
for that move but he's still in it he
it's a question mark that changes the
evaluation to says better for white by a
more noticeable margin I think it's
because the back rank could be dangerous
your move Rook E7 that is the autor
response and in fact queen8 was not the
way to capitalize uh if we I think you
should have thrown in Bishop takes C6
first dragging the queen away and only
then bringing the queen to the E8 Square
because the black king would have been
in some danger but queen8 so natural and
even after Rook E7 this is why I don't
want to fault ra it too much once you
trade Rooks on E7 the Queens don't even
necessarily have to come off if black
takes back the White Queen can start
going after some pawns on this side of
the board so be very careful with what
trades you orchestrate if you're Dennis
lazic he kind of has to as Bishop E5 in
the near future maybe after taking this
Knight on C6 T this looks scary for
Dennis all of a sudden it does and I
don't even believe black will have the
option Robert to offer that Queen trade
there might be tactics in that position
that will make it really difficult for
black to trade Queens because if you go
Rook E7 you might be forced in fact to
take it with your knight on the next
move yeah I'm just showing what you were
indicating good eye by you that maybe I
can quickly show it on the board that
Rook E7 Rook takes E7 the Knight has to
take back because if the queen takes
back Bishop takes C6 Tanya found this it
takes the Knight while protecting the
queen and removing the guard of the
black queen on E7 all at once so if you
take the bishop you do in fact lose your
queen so good eye by you Tanya this will
not be available to Dennis and if that's
the case he does not want to just trade
the Rooks and leave the White Queen back
there Rook d8 smart move by him he's
flushing the queen
out the White Queen will Retreat most
likely to the center of the board alaza
here I'm not sure why he's pausing but
he can play on the clock look at that
two and a half minutes against under one
minute now Dennis he's going to struggle
again we're back in this similar
position where he's playing Rook to D7
but now taking on C6
at least shatters the black porn
structure maybe there are options as
well it's definitely white knocking on
the door asking the questions Dennis
he's really holding together things by a
thread Bishop takes C6 looks so tempting
and Robert actually that variation you
mentioned going for the black king not
even trading Queens it's still available
for white it's still on top it is
available but not that easy to assess
properly because White's Pawn structure
is worse and Tanya he plays your
decision from earlier he's trying to
provoke G5 and make this King weaker at
some point the bishop can reroute to C2
and that H7 Pawn at long last could be
hunt Zan I like this move are you
starting to fret for Dennis Who's down
under 30 seconds Robert it's been so
instructive the way ala does these
things he provokes spawn moves he did it
against Yan NEP Nishi provoking G3 to
open up his Bishop diagonal here he's
provoking G5 to open up Black's King and
of course that would leave Ali Resa in
big danger after the bishop would
Retreat so he does sorry Dennis in big
danger Dennis does does none of that he
wants to trade Queens even if it comes
at the cost of destroying his Pawn
structure and to me at first side with
the bishop beir it is actually very
tempting to go into this end game David
do you think trading Queens here will
give some real chances to White I think
I would trade Queens just for an element
of safety for white you can kind of
press for a win with zero risk but it is
also a pawn sacrifice so maybe ala will
get tempted to capture the Black Knight
now on C6 and take on that Square twice
the white bishop and then the White
Queen can take that's a big Pawn to win
any end game would then be winning for
white but your queen temporarily would
be a bit distanced from her King I think
all are deciding how ambitious to be if
he takes Queens yes he's better but
might not win he could have gone Pawn
hunting no he chooses the safer option
and only now shatters the black pawn
structure now the white Bishop a bit
offside I would want to get that back to
the action as quickly as possible there
we go covers the entry point the black
Rook was trying to come down to D2
and uh now it's what we call a two
result game Robert white with an
advantage but is it enough that's the
huge question right now and for those of
you who thinking how can white win this
game if you can get your pawns going on
this side of the board it's I'm just
going to quickly try to draw arrows
you're going to try to break free on the
queen side over here it's a long story
but down the line black needs to be
careful about that for now the white
king will step in the center to attack
The Rook protect the pawn but black does
want to start trading some pieces as
this endgame uh you don't have enough
material left for white to go after
pawns if say the bishops get traded so
Tanya I feel like white has good winning
chances oh he trades the Rooks and he's
giving up F2 to win C7 do you like this
decision from
Ala I do because I think black's King is
far away from the Queens side pawns and
it gives white more chances also the
biggest Point here is for Dennis he's
got very little time to think if he
really wants to trade the Rooks or not
he does go for it he believes he can
hold it but ala is going to try to push
this one the king steps in coming
towards the center with a tempo right
now moving forward there will be a check
on Black's King at some point but right
now how do you break this do you try to
trade off the Bishops at some point
what's the plan forward I do like
White's position despite Black's uh
activity of the
king white simply has a better Pawn
structure the two black F pawns are
essentially just one porn uh so
therefore on the other flank the queen
side white has a three on two Advantage
as we know from any sports having an
extra body often overwhelms the opponent
and White's King can actually Journey
round towards A5 it might be headed in
that direction and yeah looks like
White's Queens side majority is going to
at least deflect the black Army maybe
just win the game on the spot I'm really
surprised I've got to say that Dennis
allowed the kind of C Pawn to drop for
the F Pawn now it's just pure suffering
and like you said Tanya key ingredient
is that white can bully the opponent
with the threat of a bishop exchange if
Bishops disappear white simply wins King
and Pa n game better Pawn structure pass
Pawn which he's about to create he is
winning Ria still some work to do Robert
to get the king in but this is the first
step well that was given a question mark
But Black's response was bad because now
the carpet is rolled out for the white
king so what Dennis needed to do was sit
put he needed to stay there with not
allowing the white king in I think you
can even give away this B Pawn at some
point use his a decoy and then the white
king marches towards the black pawns and
they will in fact fall I think Dennis
down to two seconds he knows that this
one is Ali Rises for the taking he can't
keep his miserable Pawn structure
defended Dennis could have an hour on
his clock right now and I don't see him
defending this position white has this
really strong B passer black as you
pointed out is impossible ever for him
to create counterplay on the king side
with a past pawn and combining the
threats of the B Pawn advancing forward
and the King infiltrating to that East
six square this is Ali razar's game and
now he's deflecting Black's King to
enter with his own King to grab the king
side pawns
wow that was sweet David that's
liquidation that's grinding like a
grandmas beautiful technique simplifying
the equation black king was too far away
white was even temporarily down a porn
but this is an easily winning end game
Dennis is about to resign and there we
go alaza wins the end game in perfect
style really impressive o Dennis there
just on the back foot from the off and
couldn't fight back Raza strikes
first and in a very strategically
outplayed game there by aliisa with the
white pieces there weren't too many
tactics involved he just kept the
pressure on slowly improved the position
and we see Dennis there he's perhaps
having a look at what could have gone
better but maybe it's time for him to
think about what he really wants to do
in the next game because it is the final
game for Dennis lazovic he it is a must
win win a game for dnis he starts with
the white pieces Ali Resa needs only a
draw to take the match Victory to
challenge Magnus in the Grand Final what
are our predictions right now Robert
what are the chances of Dennis making a
comeback well I was saying that Dennis
is you know the best part about his game
is he rarely loses but the struggle is
when you're playing against these super
talents like Al zaa it's not often you
win so for Dennis he needs to play
riskier chess that's not his style it's
not his nature even at the Champions
chess tour finals there were games in
the second one of the match where
instead of just going all out and risk
losing the games ended peacefully quite
quickly so I fear for Dennis being in a
hole is not good for him but if he could
beat Magnus Carlson yesterday with the
black pieces went down by a point why
not today with the white pieces against
ala good news is that Alara rarely plays
solid or I'm not even sure solid's in
his dick dictionary he often allows
chances because at some point he gets a
bit ambitious himself and kind of opens
himself up to Counterattack so Dennis
needs to get a position where he can
provoke Alara where he gets some chances
like Robert says needs to take some
risks uh he's not going to get many
opportunities in this next game Dennis
to strike back but he has to even if
it's just a half chance go on the attack
go on the front foot um I've got to say
though it's going to be really really
kind of uh debilitating this last defeat
from Dennis really hard to swallow
because he nearly never loses in that
style you rarely see Dennis get ground
down so to recover is the first step and
then to strike to go on the attack
that's the second it's quite ironic
because it feels as if ala fuja won a
game in the style of Dennis lazic it
felt like a strategic positional
Masterpiece just out playing on Space
the double Bishop pair the advantage of
the bishop pair playing a really well
good technique in the end game and now
for Denis to do the same he needs to
play in the style of alera fuja he needs
to create a mess he needs to try to get
Ali Resa into those tactical skirmishes
where both players have the opportunity
to go wrong Dennis lazic has he did
Strike Back Against the World number one
he has the potential to strike back
against Ali Resa will he manage to do it
he starts with 1 D4 and we're going to
see a Nimo
Indian I think that for Dennis lazic it
is really against his nature to uh play
some random risky line he plays Sol even
this opening he's playing E3 which is
the most principal classical way to
handle this you are allowing yourself to
get double pawns sure but in return you
control the center so this is a I think
a good start for Dennis we'll see if Ali
Resa play some of the forcing lines with
his Pawn pushing in the center but those
kind of Pawn pushes with white getting
the bishop pair there are some risk
attached David I have to say I think Al
is it should not be displeased with the
start that's uh for sure Robert and I
like the fact that alaza is pausing he's
not rushing his Mose here with black
because uh potentially he didn't expect
this uh this variation but also he's
fighting his Natural Instincts we
mentioned Alara he wants to play a
really imbalanced position but he
doesn't need to here a draw is enough
and there we go we see a quick kind of
uh breaking of the central tension a
quick exchange and Dennis has actually
had this position before I remember
commentating on some of those games so
ala must have prepared this and uh there
we go white with an isolated Queen's
Pawn but with some attacking chances
Queen to D3 watch out for that one next
white can play around that pawn lots of
central control and um yeah this still
well-known stuff very well-known Theory
and uh yeah Tanya do you think that this
is a wise choice from Dennis not
surprising the opponent he's in his Home
Comfort his home territory here but yeah
still uh super solid for black super
solid but it's imbalanced David the pawn
structure is imbalanced like you said
the isolated Queen Pawn gives black the
L long-term Advantage if pieces are
traded off that suits Black just fine
but for Dennis having the spawn in the
center it gives him those ideas of
trying to create a kingside attack we
could see the queen and the bishop line
up on the diagonal the knight from C3
could jump onto E3 the knight from E2
will try to aim to land on a kingside
square WIA g3 at some point there are
these ideas and having an imbalanced
Pawn structure it does create chances
for both players we see this retreating
move but it's often to go forward next
Black wants to try to aim to put that
Bishop on F6 not only targeting that D4
Pawn but it can be a key Defender for
all these kingside attacking ideas that
we're pointing out once black gets G6
and is able to Fan cat out the bishop
we're seeing all of this being played
out I'm also expecting alira at some
point to go B6 Bishop B7 meanwhile for
white to finish development it's a long
game but I would say in a must-win
situation Dennis should be pleased with
the opening outcome what do you think
Robert at first I was saying that Alara
should not be unhappy but the way
alara's played the last few turns it
shows me that he wants to make a draw
but it's not comfortable for him either
he's not someone who just likes to play
passively not really get a full game of
it he wants peace tension he wants
Dynamics so I think both players are
struggling with the match situation
Dennis he needs to win and yet we're in
a position where he has this isolated
pawn and black is blockading nicely ala
he just needs a draw as David said he's
not really comfortable just sitting and
doing nothing it's not to his liking so
as ala keeps thinking you look at
Dennis's clock and you're like well why
not just play on then later in the game
go for something perhaps speculative or
they puts the black king in danger David
I have to say that ala the way he's been
playing thus far suddenly it's
concerning me because I don't think he
feels quite at home it feels like uh as
we mentioned fighting those instincts
fighting the kind of Temptation to play
something a bit more uh kind of
ambitious aggressive instead he's just
trying to be super solid as black and um
that's totally fair enough that's kind
of what we expected with the match
situation but I think you're right
Robert the clock situation gives it away
alz is already down two minutes um some
of the moves he's made as
well it doesn't feel like he's too uh
comfortable at all Dennis's moves on the
other hand really natural Bishop to H6
gains a Tempo against the black Rook the
white Rooks now will flood towards the
center um firstly you have to choose
squares I'm always a bit tensi about
which squares to choose is it D1 E1 C1
but that's Dennis's Choice luckily not
mine and it will come down to whether at
some point fua can just break the
tension trade off some pieces and uh
guide it towards safety even if he's not
comfortable uh here Tanya even if this
isn't his kind of normal Play Zone uh
forja his his moves are natural as well
Bishop to B7 next move and uh yeah it's
hard to imagine anything going wrong at
least in the near
future and I saw a feature chat there
saying that if Ala plays for a draw he
will lose and I think very often that is
uh we see that happen quite a bit when a
player just needs a draw you don't take
those objective decision you play too
much for a draw going against your own
instincts going against your own
intuition and that can backfire but Ali
Resa right we saw him what he did in his
match against Yan pishi he traded off
all the pieces when he needed to even
though he had a better position because
that worked for the match we're seeing
him with that similar approach here he
wants to try to keep things under
control but again I'm going to repeat I
I think for Dennis he's got reasons to
be pleased with this outcome it isn't
better for white Black's doing fine yes
he's got the iqp with white but it still
feels like there are so many pieces on
the board not a single set of minor
pieces has been traded off if ever black
takes on C3 at any moment white can
recapture with the B Pawn making sure
that the B Pawn and the the C Pawn are
connected and there's no more iqp you
were talking about who is it easier to
play I also see moves like Rook E1 Rook
D1 coming in this is going to be a big
fight Robert it is and I think for
Dennis he will have to follow up this
move Queen F3 which I like follow this
one up quickly there's already an idea
can I take on D5 then black will be
saddled with an isolated Pawn but what
you need to calculate is can black take
with the queen I'm not so sure as Bishop
E4 comes to mind and now there's some
problems on the diagonal and if Knight
takes D5 e takes D5 you both get
isolated pawns it's about who can
operate around it but instead Dennis and
I don't want symmetry I'm going to place
my Bishop on e4 Tanya your point is well
taken Knight takes C3 you can take back
with the pawn and sort of fix your Pawn
structure at least transition from
isolated Pawn to a bit of a hanging Pawn
structure and hanging Pawn structures
are known for their Dynamic
opportunities David I have to say the
last couple of moves I both players are
playing accurately good chess but I
still am liking how the game is going
from White's perspective at least until
I just saw this move Knight A5 that is a
very good decision from Ali Raza a very
good decision he's uh essentially just
preparing for all of these exchanges now
if white does take on D5 we'll see
Bishops Knights Queens potentially even
disappear and not good news for Dennis
lavic in a situation he needs to win
that will just fizzle out towards
equality so now this stronghold that one
square that you've highlighted there the
Red Square D5 black can play around it
the Black Knight might come into C4
Black's Rook will come to C8 um I also
want to mention one kind of uh thing for
Dennis Le laic to worry about he's not
used to having worse porn structures we
talk about him as a grinder he loves
just having kind of really harmonious
structures where he's got the kind of
the long-term trumps up his sleeve I
think the pressure of having the
isolated Queens porn that we've been
talking about that is not an easy kind
of uh structure to handle so wise choice
maybe from fua and black position uh as
with you Robert I feel it's growing on
me looks like fuja he's stabilized and
that is the key here um Tanya Tanya you
mentioned you liked White's natural
moves um what do you think he should be
doing next what's uh the next step for
Dennis lazovic in his quest for victory
well Dennis is in a thing so it can't be
that easy if you have to play
intuitively here you think about
bringing your Rooks to the game either
The Rook comes to E1 or the other Rook
comes to C1 but the bigger question I
think about this position has to be more
of an overview because we might even see
a pawn structure transformation from an
isolated Queen's Pawn in a couple of
moves we might see a fixed Pawn
structure in the center with the trades
on D5 and I think we have to think and
talk about that because if black is able
to get a Pawn on D5 and white has a Pawn
on D4 and imagine all the pieces the
bishop the light Square Bishop's traded
off the knights are traded off the
Queens are off the board and you get
this Pawn structure then the fact that
alira has a dark Square vision Bishop
which can Target D4 and Tennis will be
left with a dark Square Bishop which
cannot Target D5 that works in Ali rza's
favor so trades are super important he's
he avoids them right now because I
really think he needs to keep pieces on
the board he needs to continue playing
with this isolated Queen pawn and not go
for that fixed Center that was a very
good and deep Point by Tanya that this
D4 Pawn is on the same color as this
bishop on E7 which means the bishop can
go after it and wh's Bishop on a dark
Square can't go after any of the light
pawns so look at Dennis he first brings
his Rook to a fully open file I would
expect that black is tempted to do the
same but now we are speaking about
tactics and this D5 Knight may be
captured here and I just want to go down
one quick uh little hole Rabbit Hole of
analysis because Rook C8 I think that's
a move you play an automatic move but if
we can look at this line and Knight
takes D5 if you just take back on D5
well this Rook takes on C8 and now the
bishop or the queen is distracted until
you drop this Pawn in the center of
course the game continues it's not like
black has lost but if you play with your
hand rather than playing with your brain
you could drop a pawn immediately so
Rook C8 a natural idea but not the right
time for it in the game I expect well
Bishop to F6 Tanya's move looks very
strong to me this Knight of course wants
to go into C4 but there still will be
tactics with this Rook lined up on C1 so
I think Dennis's last move David to my
eyes looks like a great choice and it's
causing Ali Rea to
think that's a really important step to
force the opponent down on the clock
that's where his chances will lie after
all Dennis lazic he needs to stay ahead
of the opponent we saw the clock come
back to bite him yesterday against
Magnus earlier uh in the first game
against fua Rook C1 all of these little
hidden nuances these little tactics
little bit of calculation to do for the
first time fja ultimately I think black
is still still super solid you can just
wait Queen to D7 for example I don't see
any rush and then start to connect the
black Rooks bring one to C8 um black is
still fine but yeah the clock situation
healthier than ever this is Dennis's
chance these next few moves we talked
about urgency earlier in another match
this is urgent these next few moves um
because otherwise pieces will disappear
those lines that we showed if they work
for black then it's Total Safety there's
nothing in between really it's not a
playable Advantage for white um so wow
fuja decided to trade Dart Square
Bishops big decision and uh we talked
about those Bishops the dynamic between
them in an AME favoring black long term
looks like white is forced to trade them
off but what next Tanya um who's happier
about this uh other than the clock
situation where Dennis now suddenly
up if white can trade these dark Squad
Bishops and trade everything on the
Central Square as well well step one
done and take everything on D5 I would
think that there's reason to be happy if
you take Knight takes D5 at this moment
and if black was to respond I don't
think black should recapture with the
pawn I think that would be a big
strategic mistake but if you were to
take Pawn takes Knight just fall back
with the bishop and I think the trades
really start favoring white the big
question is what if black takes with the
bishop himself and we actually see a
bunch of Trades happen what do we think
about that end game wh's got control
over the C file a knight which can
perhaps Target the D5 Pawn even sooner
and if not is there anything better than
that Robert does white keep the tension
or does white go for these
trades difficult choice right now
because the more trades that happen
often times in the back of our head
we're like the more likely it's going to
be a draw this is not a position with
extra material for either side in fact
both players have placed their pieces on
strong squares this night on the rim
it's not dim because there are actually
some key squares some light squares the
Knight can jump into and White's pieces
they're all protecting one another so T
I'm with you I'm also tempted to take on
D5 slam a rook down on C7 but I note
that even when my Rook lands on C7 the
black Rook can step up so I think black
is just in time in so many of these
different positions when white tries to
go in the offensive pieces get traded
and that would scare me if I'm Dennis
but also would scare me David is that
Dennis is now below four minutes and
we've seen him get in time trouble and
it's what Magnus said the Dennis he
needs to conserve more time because you
can't live on just seconds against these
top
players these top players they sharks
sense a bit of weakness and they really
really kind of up their level of
trickery once you're low on time um I
think Dennis is fighting against his
inner demons here he wants to take on D5
if he didn't need to win at all costs he
would play that move instantly because
it removes all risk for white but as you
mentioned lower risk also lower uh lower
potential reward there unfortunately and
I'm looking at the body language Dennis
o looks stressed alaza I mean I'm not an
expert but he looks super chill to me
Tanya he looks like like he's got
everything under control and if 1965
happens I think a draw is still the most
likely result so I think uh is it
Justified Al's uh kind of state of mind
right now very different body language
is there and you don't need to be an
expert to actually see how relaxed Ali
Rai is about his position and completely
agree the problem for danis here is not
the position on the board White's doing
absolutely fine maybe perhaps why it's
even happy to get this position that you
do because that Bishop on B7 it's behind
its own Pawn Bishop will be more active
you can jump in with that Rook to C7
Force black to trade on E7 then just
fall back with the bishop and keep
playing but it's never going to be
enough to call it call it close to
getting those big chances to create a
mess it's a symmetrical Pawn stru now
and given the map situation that's just
not enough for Dennis
Lac and not clear where he puts his
pieces from here as you said the uh
roles have been reversed a bit that's
now the black Pawn on D5 that will be
weaker than the white Pawn on D4 because
the light score Bishop can attack it but
that's not enough to say at some point
maybe I'll get to attack a pawn and we
are going down a direct line so Rook E7
that was given a brilliant move
interesting I think it's because it
sacrificed a piece but it wasn't a real
sacrifice but we're going down a forcing
path because Bishop takes Queen takes it
looks like a knight is hanging but don't
forget about your rook in the corner so
suddenly Dennis up a pawn but David I'm
looking at this and I think that black
has a couple choices bring a rook C8
bring a rook to E8 bring a rook to d8 in
the center and then this Knight for
black will go into sore like C4 I feel
like Black's going to be able to regain
the
pawn feels like it's within the Realms
of equality likely a draw if black is
accurate but it is still a bit of an if
and I like the fact that Dennis has gone
for this variation because when you're
low on time as we mentioned earlier you
need to find forcing moves you need just
easy kind of instinctive moves available
if he'd retreated and not gone for this
then I would have actually feared him
even surviving that game and uh a
question mark meanwhile Tanya attached
to the most natural move in the position
now the White Queen is hit the White
Knight is hit but um okay Dennis clings
onto his Pawn uh how big do you think
his winning chances here I'm gonna be
honest I actually missed that after Rook
E7 black ends up losing the D5 pawn and
that it's not over till you don't gain
that pawn or create direct activity also
notice the lack of Harmony in Black
species that Knight on A5 it's not
coming back into the the game for a
while right now Queen E4 a nice
centralized Square there white can start
improving his own pieces put that Rook
from F1 to D1 start defending that D4
Pawn to free your own Knight it's an
extra Pawn for white and I have to say
that's the most that Dennis has had this
entire game Robert I'm giving and noting
an extra Pawn on D4 that's a good Pawn
right there and I want to point out a
star move by Dennis lazic instead of
retreating back to F3 which was super
tempting he covers the C4 Square he
covers the B3 Square so what I was
talking about when I threw to David
before was the Black Knight would get in
and likely that ala gets his Pawn back
no he is not getting his Pawn Back That
Remains on D4 the Knight it can't jump
into C4 technically perhaps he can get
to B3 at some point because the White
Queen is tied to the 92 but that's just
playing for tricks I like what Dennis
has accomplished here and ala he's the
one who should feel a bit nervous he's
glad to bee on time he's unhappy to be
down upon PA that by the way can start
pushing and once it starts it may not be
able to stop
Tanya completely agree D5 a big threat
and once that white knight comes into
the game it's going to be more difficult
David I see that evalar seems to say
that things are still level for black
but do you think that's deceptive does
Dennis have real chances here very
deceptive it's definitely up to fuia to
prove it and yes the Evan bar might say
level but it's going to be a really
narrow path for black with supremely
high accuracy needed and uh it okay Rook
to C8 really nice move actually
threatening to come in and especially
while white king is vulnerable on the
back rank you do start to feel a bit
nervous um I was going to say that
feature chat earlier if Dennis goes and
wins this game that feature chat earlier
saying playing for a draw is risky that
will just be inspired and we'll need to
bring it back because it feels like ala
was playing complacently for a draw for
a long time understandably so but now he
really needs to up his game Knight C3
blocks that black Rook but the black
queen does have an active Square to jump
to I'm seeing tactics all over the place
now big threats on the board Rook
tonight would undermine White's rook and
suddenly Dennis on the defensive there
was a big threat he moves The Rook away
but Black's Queen has entered that's
always a bit scary the blue arrow gives
it away Queen D2 the best move found by
fua 50 seconds against two minutes
Robert do you think he can still keep
enough control here to utilize his extra
Pawn I think that Al is doing everything
correct he hitting the Rook on one
hitting the pawn on D4 and if you go
back to D1 we've seen this position
before and that Rook takes C3 threat
undermining the defense of the Rook as
you said that is what's keeping black in
the game so he goes for the Czech batana
all of the advantage allegedly is gone
it's given a question mark But while we
see the Rooks come off the board this
pass Pawn could be more dangerous if
white is able to keep it and after Queen
E5 check it looks like you are that's
going to be the absolute key right can
white hold on to this pawn and the big
Advantage for white is the the Knight on
A5 is still one move away from coming to
the game but watch out there are back
rank threats once the black king falls
back our blue arrow is telling us King
G8 is the best move white doesn't have
time to start pushing that D Pawn just
yet there's a big threat Queen C1 is
Checkmate so you've still got to push
one create a lift for your king go H3 he
goes H4 denn is being more aggressive
right now also eying to clamp down Alpha
zero style H 586 creating a mating net
against the black king
uh finally Black's Knight is in the game
but I think this is going to start
getting tricky Queen Knight versus queen
Knight we might be seeing tactics very
soon David definitely already massive
threats there the White Knight is
hopping in uh leaping in and uh yeah
let's forget the evaluation bar for now
queen of knights as we've seen multiple
times throughout division one this
season already uh during the Chester bow
Masters there's such a fearsome
attacking Duo The Perfect combo if
you're going for the opponent's king so
Dennis he's left himself with enough
ingredients here enough ammunition to
cause threats yes it should be a draw
because pawns are disappearing I'm
assuming Black's going to take on B2 I'm
not sure with which piece and uh if the
Queens ever disappear black is totally
safe but uh for now there's still
sufficient winning chances one hurdle
here Robert though I'm still looking at
that clock 30 seconds it could go wrong
so quickly it can but it's also easier
for white to play because White's King
is safe and sound and it's Black's King
that might be in a checkmating net as we
were highlighting the Knight hopping
into E7 the black king goes to f8 and
just one slip away from getting
checkmated so Knight D5 is automatic I
think that Dennis has to play quickly
here it's given the blue arrow that's
not me but Knight E7 check all of a
sudden it's uncomfortable for ala and he
may have a series of only moves himself
you don't just take a Pawn on A3 it's
not the time to go Pawn grabbing in this
position Tanya you have to be worried
for Al is in fact that move the
advantage is going up for
white just it's going to be it's going
to be a time scramble both players under
a minute now Dennis is playing under 20
seconds and it's also good news for
white that you played the move H4
because you not only created a lift on
H2 also a potential lift on H3 when
required he needs to watch out there are
lines to calculate comes in with a check
black has to move you still can't push
the D Pawn the Knight on E7 it can't be
picked up Queen takes Knight would lose
to queen h8 that Knight was not on
preate threat Queen h8 is a big threat
black needs to play King G8 we see it
Robert there with the blue arrow only
move fi's got 30 seconds he has to find
it and he does the game laic down to two
seconds when he made that move let's
remind everybody they gain two seconds
with every move they play White is up a
pawn again Knight takes A3 maybe the B6
Pawn drops so if this D Pawn survives I
would actually try to push it as soon as
I can and with the Knight maybe coming
back to C6 D5 is available with forks on
E7 this is really tricky Ali reaza Tanya
he's down under 20 seconds himself
yeah this is just m skills and they have
to be tactically so sharp with meting
ideas against the black king white needs
to watch out for any Perpetual themes
with Queen F4 check but that Queen on F6
does a brilliant job the Deep PA has
started advancing do not grab it there's
a big fork on E7 things are getting
really tricky and out of control here
for black but can he go for a queen
trade he does it because Knight jumps
back to E5 defending the D7 Square
certain control but wow there was a
moment that white porn could have have
pushed forward could it push forward now
it's going to be a race Dennis shaking
his head he has to work out that he can
make he can push the point he can win
the Knight and the Knight gets back to
stop the B Pawn just in time he's a
piece up but is it enough Robert he's
winning a KN for Pawn of material but
the Knight is going to be paralyzed to
the that bwn but the evaluation bar it's
at zeros but it's misleading I actually
think white has chances to win this game
and you actually see it's starting to
creep up a little bit the engine itself
not sure this isn't a table-based
position too many pieces remain
objectively with proper play it should
be a draw but let's say you push your
Pawn too early you may create weaknesses
and white can waste the tempo this
Knight can go back and forth and you
already see that the makings of a
position where opposition may be
required so David this is an end game
that's not familiar to either player
mistakes happen especially under five
seconds for each player look like more
mistakes are bound to happen it should
be a draw but black is barely Clinging
On Here White's King at the right moment
is going to make a dart there we go for
that black H Pawn and now again it's a
race can black just go for this white
knight now he's going for it forua but
it's a race between the White H Pawn and
the black B Pawn I think he's just in
time here forja to hold the draw four
seconds for Dennis Tanya I think it's
about to end nothing to do no way to
keep the game
going and I think it's h it's going to
happen now this was a desperate try
Dennis could not keep the Knight alive
they're going to Queen at the same time
Dennis has to win he's trying to do that
both players will Queen at the same time
but it's Black's move as well it's alza
who has the extra Pawn it's not going to
be enough to even create a chance here
for Dennis extra Pawn for Ali Raza but
misplaced King so if this queen can
somehow grab this F5 Pawn you start to
feel like you have chances but look at
Ali Rea bringing his Queen to the
defense of both giving some checks you
don't want to drop either of these pawns
so his Queen is in the perfect place Ali
re he has this under control at this
stage with with Dennis credit to him he
played what should have been apparently
a losing move but a draw is the
equivalent of loss for Dennis at this
stage ala only needs to secure this half
point and that was such a special
position being down at night and knowing
that you can hold it David how confident
do you think Ali Resa was going into
that end game it was more necessity than
out of confidence that he went for that
fua in the meantime it is a draw it is
fua who progresses but Dennis threw
everything at the game he got so close a
lot of credit to him wow what a Tipsy
Topsy Turvy game he came so close
heartbreaking but he's so impressive the
youngster it is the end of the road in
the chable Masters for the 17-year-old
Dennis lazic but he has left a big
impression on the world with his play
and undoubtedly will be back in the
champions chesta We can't wait to have
him back in the fight as well eventually
goes down to Ala fuja and Robert Magnus
Carlson gets the match that he
wanted Magnus Carlson asked and
sometimes he shall receive it didn't
happen for the classical World
Championship it is happening here in the
ches Masters Ali Raza fua was on the
brink of elimination from the very start
of this event after losing a one
position sure but not in that time
scramble against Bosa so for Aliva fuja
to storm back to beat everybody that was
in his path including super Grand
Masters like Wesley so and yand pomi and
Superstar teenagers like Dennis lvic
credit to fua he's been on a tear and
he's earned his spot against Magnus in
the chesf masters Grand
Final and it's going to be such such a
fantastic match that one but this was
such a big fight as well David Dennis
lazic holding his own yesterday against
Magnus and then today against Ali RZA as
well fighting back so close to bouncing
back in this match in that second
game Dennis was so close in that second
game but ultimately it wasn't to be
all's defenses were too strong were too
sturdy but I wanted to actually
highlight in the earlier game the
decisive game ultimately where alera
broke through Dennis's defenses to win
the game win the match and I just wanted
to highlight this final point the
technique the endgame technique really
really instructive here white has
entered white has broken through the
white King on a fantastic Square the
white B Pawn close to touchdown but the
black king is nearby how to land the
finishing touches black played the move
Bishop F4 covering the promotion square
and this is Testament to alosa F's
judgment his calculation his
understanding he played Pawn to B7 it
looks over hasty suddenly the pawn drops
off King to C7 but in this position he'd
worked out a long variation starting
with a check always look for checks
first double exclamation mark this is a
mathematical equation simplifying things
the black Bishop is forced to capture
now check giving away your pride and joy
deflecting the black king and after the
bishop disappears look at the uh just
just uh the race here the white king
simply too close too near the Black
porns and Black's King too far away it
was in this position Dennis lazic
resigned because the white F Pawn is
soon to step forward and soon to become
a new fire from fuja In the End
Game beautiful instructive endgame
technique on displ by alira fuja in that
one and the next one as well a difficult
end game that he did hold and with that
hold he takes the match Victory and gets
the spot into the chessel masters Grand
Final we're going to go into a quick
break and we will be back with Ali Raza
fuja you don't want to miss it stay with
[Music]
us
the year-long Champions chess tour
consists of four main online events and
one live final each event will begin
with a playin tournament open to all
Grand Masters and top finishers from
qualifying events 69 play players from
the playin will be joined on the second
day by the four qualifiers from the
previous Tour event match play with 73
players will then determine placement
across all three divisions division play
then commences with 6 days of Double
Elimination Brackets the last player
standing are your winners the winner of
division 1 qualifies directly to the
cctt finals the winner of division 2
secures a spot in division 1 at the next
Tour event while the winner of division
3 is guaranteed at least a spot in
division 2 in each event players also
ACR points for the season long
leaderboard the final standings will
decide who joins our division 1 winners
at the yearend CCT live finals each
regular season event will feature a
whopping
$300,000 prize pool while the final
eight players will battle it out for
their part in half a million dollars in
prizes at the final that's one .7
million up for grabs in the 2024
Champions chess tour so tune in and
watch all the action as the best chess
players in the world compete to be
crowned the next CCT
Champion hello can I get 50 L back
please because one of my friends played
on my account and lost 50 thank you I've
got friends like that too when I'm
frustrated or in a bad mood some
May a little bit you know what maybe a
little maybe you know I don't know it's
been a good night yeah now I friends
just like that man they they come on my
account I wake up in the morning yeah
well the good news is um better to have
friends who lose you rating points then
gain you rating points cuz then your
account might be closed for cheating Pro
tip I am deeply sorry for the language I
used I will never ever ever use vulgar
language again I'm so please unburn me
please
you are my star and my sunshine I go to
bed daming of you and when I wake up I
think of you again so I ask kindly
please chess.com come with me to pom
hugs and kisses we love you too unmute
that man we love you too I wubo MBL I
feel like we were being taunted just a
little bit there um but at the same time
I'm not one to judge anyone's speech
impediment you know and so welcome
welcome you whisky wabbit I don't know
what else to say and it's a gaming site
you know when people write in and
they've got the right sense of humor it
means a lot to us cuz you know that's
that's the kind of um The Vibes we
[Music]
want
oh
[Music]
and we're back with our grand finalist
of the chass Masters ala fua ala
congratulations firstly and I am going
to ask you that it's been a long but a
really rewarding day firstly tell us how
are you
feeling I'm feeling very I have a lot of
adrenaline I think
especially the game against nepo was
very tiring and breathtaking so I'm
happy to make
it you had three draws in that match and
let's start with that match against Yan
it was peaceful result in all of them
but the games were absolutely crazy they
were a lot of fun to watch were they fun
to
play yeah sure because both of us have
very tactical and very aggressive style
so it always whenever I'm playing him um
um I I try to get out of the opening
somehow so I start the position with
start the game with worst position
either color but then I try to make it
interesting and
unbalanced so when you're playing
against a player like neppo are you
expecting it to get into wild ter
territory yeah I'm expecting it but most
of the times it's not possible because
he he's he has checked all the openings
so it's very hard to against him to get
a game but it's time to time it's
possible but it's definitely in Rapid it
helps that the time is
less and then going into the Armageddon
in that match against Yan we were
discussing if perhaps your bid was too
low it was I think 6 minutes and 40
seconds if I'm not wrong around that
much time what was your approach were
you really wanting uh to play with black
there yeah yeah of course I wanted to
play with black because for me I think
it doesn't matter two three minutes
because um I could play fast and um I
think I could recover that so and if I
have result
odds uh it helps but um depends on the
opponent also but yeah I think I'm
comfortable with the having less
time yeah and then that was a really
cool Armageddon and you took the match
in that one and then going into the next
one immediately you have to play Dennis
who's been phenomenal in this tournament
so far he's taken down so many of the
big names what was your approach getting
into that uh final fight in the
elimination
bracket yeah I was happy playing against
Dennis because his style is not very
aggressive so I could have a time to
recover from the match against nepo and
getting the game because he normally
doesn't play aggressive from the very
beginning so um uh he's a very strong
player of course he beat everybody
almost in this tournament so I expected
to be a very hard match but I thought I
have good chances to
win and how does it go when you're
preparing for such a match do you go
through those games that Dennis has had
with uh with Anish with Hikaru with
Magnus no I didn't prepare for Dennis
actually I just prepared a beat for
neple and that's it I said if I go
through nepo then I will somehow do
something this then is so
um I said the first step is more
important one step at a time and you
made it through uh you mentioned that
you know you didn't mind compromising on
those extra minutes when it comes to the
Armageddon how are you finding this new
time format uh what do you think about
this time control
change yeah I think it definitely is
better that we play 10 plus two because
I felt 15 plus two is too long and the
whole format of Championship story is to
make it less shorter time control so um
at least for me it's a pretty good
change with less time so um I'm happy
but I think everybody in general is
happy with the change yeah and I think
the fans are really happy as well
because it means more entertainment for
all of us alira how have you overall
been feeling about your play so far in
the chessel
Masters I think I played a very good
chess until here the one match that I
lost is fedos was
very it was not a very good day and I
was very unlucky in that match I think
and I was up the first game and then I
lost the second game with white the I
blonded really badly so but in general
I'm very happy my play I think um I
don't think I know that I need to change
so much um for the fin Grand Final if I
have if I keep playing this level I have
chances I think and that's the big one
coming up it's on Wednesday you will be
playing against uh Magnus we're all very
excited about that matchup looking ahead
into it uh how do you think about uh the
fight that's coming up of course without
giving anything away what what would be
your uh strategy to go into that Grand
Final knowing that you have to beat
Magnus
twice yeah of course
beating disadvantage is really big for
him because um he could play without any
pressure
the first match so um for instance in if
it gets to Armageddon then it will be a
big um Advantage for him because then he
plays the Armageddon without woring so
much so it would be very tough but um
forance Maxim did it before so I think
there are chances but um yeah it will be
very de you yeah I was just about to say
Maxine's done it so there's uh a lot of
inspiration to to take from that one as
well we're really excited about it uh
and chat's really excited about it we've
got a chat question for you I'm going to
bring that that up it's by U oh my gosh
I don't even know how to pronounce this
I'm going to skip the name but um how do
you feel about your playing style
against Magnus considering he struggled
with it in the
past yeah I
think um he's now make like trying to be
more comfortable with my style for my
kind of style um he's trying different
positions different tactical positions
so he's adapting to it I think so he's
playing much better than three four
years ago the against the people that
has my style like very aggressive and um
that's why probably he's meeting more
more tournaments now so um it would be
difficult but I think I always have
chances against him because
um because of my style and everything
and we talk about your style a lot ala
if you had to sort of describe it uh
just elaborate it a little bit for us
how would you describe your own style of
play yeah I
think I think not easy to describe it
it's
just um I play a lot with intuition
probably I don't like for instance
Fabiano calculates a lot
but I don't have the patience so much to
calculate so I just play more int
intuitively so maybe that's the that way
you can describe
it and do you think having this
intuition uh this style of uh relying
more on intuition especially works with
low with less time on the
clock yeah of course it helps because I
played thousands of bullet game so it's
um of course I have that also so it
helps of course
yeah it's awesome to see you with
seconds on the clock and the speed that
you bring on and we got one more
question from huan Kalos and he wants to
know what do the next couple of months
look like for you in the leadup to the
candidates I will play the 960
tournament in Germany in two three days
and then and then I don't have anything
so I have to prepare and um yeah I'm
working a lot on chest now so for the
candidates you must be really uh looking
forward to that it's a really big one
coming up in
April yeah of course the chance that I
managed to make it to candid so I will
definitely try to use the best out of it
so but it will be very tough very long
so um I will try to prepare very hard
for it but yeah it could go uh it would
it will be
interesting we look forward to watching
you in the candidates and we really look
forward to watching you on Wednesday
battle out against Magnus alza we'll see
you then thank you thank you ala fuja
books his spot into the Grand Final and
online will on the line will be the
ticket the golden ticket to the season
end tour final Magnus Carlson wanted to
fight Ali Rea he gets his wish and what
a day of Chess it's been David alira
really earned his spot into that Grand
Final yeah we said beforehand if he were
to get there he would have to do it the
hard way it was three really tough games
against yand pomi and he had to dig deep
to find the extra energy to defeat
fellow youngster Dennis lazic impressive
stuff and uh he looked full of
confidence in that interview with you
Tanya I think he's going to fancy his
chance to secretly against
Magnus yeah and it's also so interesting
with these Dynamics Robert of the
candidates coming up players of course
don't want to reveal too much of their
preparation they don't want to reveal
anything about their preparation how do
you think that would play out in this
big Grand Final with so much on the line
well against Magnus Carlson you kind of
expect that the number one rated player
in the world will play whatever he feels
like so it's not even like preparation
often helps you against him I think alza
at this moment he's just happy to secure
a minimum second place finish which
means we'll see him in division one in
our second event of the tour so for all
you ala fans out there you should be
particularly happy about that so I think
considering he lost his first match Al
he's not even considering what Magnus
will play he's just uh taking in this
great day he gets a day off tomorrow and
preparation that's for another time he's
not going to worry about it
yet it's going to be a big fight when
the two play each other and of course Al
has to beat Magnus not once but twice in
that grand final but there is a certain
Maxim V lra who's done it before so it
is possible as he said one step at a
time uh and before before we wrap up
let's bring up our chessable masters
standings presented by our wealth
management Partners Julius bear and
there we've got more fill in- the blanks
being filled up right there with danis
Lai the end of their journey in the
chable Masters Dennis with a pig
paycheck of $115,000 for all the hard
work that he's done a very well-deserved
prize there and yashi goes back with
$125,000 tomorrow the big fight for for
a lot of money tour points and the big
ticket to the season and final David
before we wrap up before we say goodbye
to our chat I'm going to open the floor
to you for your final thoughts on the
day that we just had in division one
it's been as bloodthirsty as ever it
feels like we're saying goodbye to these
huge names day by day uh ultimately it
was a Triumph of Youth with ala OV
experience with Yan ponesi and I just
want to say Dennis lazic
I mean get used to that name everyone
we'll see him back at this point but
most of all just excitement for the
final on Wednesday yeah we keep talking
about the finals on Wednesday so
everyone at home Must Be Wondering
what's happening tomorrow we will cover
the division 2 and division 3 Grand
finals and awaiting the winner coming up
from the losers final is Vincent kimer
he took down leavon aronian in the
Winner's final now leavon he's duking
out with Benjamin Bach that should be a
familiar name to you all because he's a
popular streamer and content creator and
also a Dutch Grandmaster who when it
comes down to it he can fight with the
best of them look who he beat in the
loser semi-final vladislav artmia before
that he took down Anish giri and this is
a huge bracket so large in fact that I
can't see it I wear glasses for a reason
but we are Whittle down to just three
players leavon aronian fighting for his
life in the losers final against
Benjamin box bin kimer that's a junior a
prodigy and someone we gladly get to
watch
tomorrow spicy matches coming up in
division 2 Division 3 it will be the
final day and of course there's a lot on
the line for the players there as well
there's store points there's direct spot
into the next Champions chest store
division one so much to play for so much
to fight for and all of that will be
before the big Grand Final where Magnus
cson will take on the Ala fuja we didn't
get that world championship who we get a
chessable master is a grand final it's
going to be a big day of Chess has been
a big day of Chess as well it's been a
pleasure Robert David chat it's a
goodbye from us we will see you
[Music]
tomorrow
he
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
he